Loud.
Okaidinaasaiyimase, go shenjin-tama, goit-go-shama.
Hello.
Moe, moe, boo!
My voice is still dead.
I'm still dead, sorry.
Hello.
Actually, hold on.
I'm going to move over.
Let's see.
If I do this.
Chica, chica, chica, chica, chica, chica.
Oh wait, I'm stupid.
Where am I doing that?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Yeah.
That sound better today?
I think so.
Yippee!
Needed a minute to take the Snake Ocelot?
Well, people...
Oh, yeah, definitely.
You know, that was a real big concern of mine.
I'd be so embarrassed if you guys saw that.
Because you guys would never expect that of me.
Peak fiction incoming.
Let me make sure mine.
Okay.
Okay, good.
I'm playing this on controller.
I don't even know if this is a controller game, but I would
have to plug in a mouse and stuff to my other...
desktop.
As you can see, well, first of all, hello everybody.
Welcome to
OneShot.
I'm playing on my tiny PC that you can see.
I've played Mystery of the Druids and Harvester on.
And I'm playing on desktop Scary!
So scary!
Wait a second.
Actually, I want to do something real quick before I...
I'm gonna disconnect from the internet.
I don't think anything will happen, but I'm scared.
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
Wait, why is my mouse not working?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, good.
Disconnect.
Roadrunner cartoons.
What the heck are some of these?
Anyway, okay.
You didn't clear your history on this PC?
Okay, that's not what I'm afraid of.
Actually, no, you guys don't know what I'm into.
Maybe I would be a little scared of that.
There we go, okay.
Yeah, we're off the grid.
We're off the grid.
But welcome to Lenshot.
um change to an anime desktop well okay i thought about it
but i was like when i don't have an anime desktop or anime
wallpaper for this i know it's like my throwaway not
throwaway pc but you know the pc i don't use so i have to
have it a non-anime wallpaper
starting off my birthday by supporting my kamioshi oh my
gosh i've always been a shy supporter, but if I learn
anything from Minto, is that I should be proud of the things
I love?
Yes, this, this, this, this.
Plus one of those things?
Is it you?
Thank you!
Wait, is it?
Is it Lonari or Aionari?
Which one?
Hello, Minto, and Aibu is like you, my tip for today.
Make sure your PC name isn't revealing or Fouiki.
Mine is Lunari!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Yeah, my very freaky computer name is...
Admin.
Also, my Koharu wallpapers are all on my laptop.
I wonder if I should start using my laptop for this instead.
Well, no, my tiny PC works so
Well...
Adminto.
Also, this game is kind of funky.
Like, hold on, I mean.
Uh...
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Did it disconnect?
Oh!
Why isn't it working?
Allow.
allow wait oh let me click on okay hold on click there we go
so there's like only full screen and obviously that works
like not very well on my actual desktop so that's why it's
not full screen here also i know the thing is is i don't
know anything about the story of this game but when you are
typically have to know games that are going to show file
names and things of the such so um i was told this game is
best played um best played in windowed mode so that's why
we're in window mode so i apologize you see the you see my
my very normie looking
So, yes.
Yeah, so unfortunately, you know, those kinds of meta things
are great if you're playing, like, by yourself.
But if you're streaming, you kind of have to know those
types of things.
So I apologize in advance.
Best played on Minto mode.
Yeah, frame skip on.
Do I need that?
I'm scared what if I accidentally press too fast Love you,
Minto Thank you Thanks for the whole year Thank you Thank
you, thank you Norm, Clarminto I'm such a normie Actually Do
you guys ever wish you could be more normie?
Sometimes I wish I could like You know, I've had like Office
jobs and things But I No!
Sometimes I wish I could like...
I know how... I wish I knew how to talk to people.
You know what I mean?
Dream Chaser, thank you so much for the gift!
Thank you!
Sometimes I just wish I could like...
Like have a normal conversation with...
Like I don't know how to talk to people if it's not about
like...
Animated stuff.
You know what I mean?
I love the Mount plausible deniability.
Don't check my history background.
I especially appreciate the mystery of the druids icon on
your desktop.
Yeah, this is the computer I played it on.
Bionic hippo!
You.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifts.
And also, I saw what you sent offline.
I saw what you sent to me!
I saw that you said, don't know nerd I saw but thank you I
really appreciate it sometimes think about how boring my
life would be without me though in the world you introduced
to me to be a boy I can't wait in wait in my life no well
you know at the same time.
Normie, me has a wife and kids, so I'm good as is.
Is that your alter ego or are you saying you're Normie?
What?
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Speaking of wife and kids, I just finished season two of
Breaking Bad, like, right before stream.
I just finished the season two of Breaking Bad right before
stream.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I met Gus.
I met Gus.
I know that guy.
Oh, wow.
Oh, my gosh.
And it ended with Skylar being like...
At first, I was kind of like...
Okay.
She...
Okay, hold on.
I have to talk about Breaking Bad for a second.
Season 3 is peak.
When does he throw the pizza?
Is that season 3?
Um.
Okay, wait.
Okay, I have to talk about...
It is!
Do
you like Saul?
I want to really watch The Better Call Saul now Because of
how he is Okay, I really thought Okay, I totally judged a
book by his cover I'll be 100% honest I will I completely
thought this guy was gonna be a weenie I thought he was
gonna be like a few reactions to the show.
I thought he was gonna be like a little like kind of timid,
nervous guy like, um, I know I know I get into some pretty
shady things, but I'm little Saul and, but he's kind of
like, he's like a weenie, but he's like um, he's like a,
he's like he's a literal, like a literal, literal worm.
He's like such a worm.
But God.
yeah a weasel that's a great way to put it he's like an
actual weasel turned human uh no offense to the weasels but
oh my gosh so okay end of season two the very last episode
oh my gosh first of all i'm i'm mad at jesse right now i
feel bad for him but i'm mad at him I'm trying to be as
non-spoilery as possible.
I'm mad at Jesse.
I'm mad at him.
I'm really mad at him.
I don't feel bad for him, but I'm mad at him.
Why would he do that?
Yeah, Jesse's going through it.
But like, he did it to himself!
I'm so angry.
Ugh!
Not angry, just disappointed.
I think that's it, man.
And...
So, at the very, like, one of the very last scenes...
When Skylar is going off on Walter...
At first I was like...
Because, okay, he is about to have the surgery, right?
And then he says the thing...
About the cell phones.
And Skylar's like...
Click!
And then she goes...
Then she goes off on him.
And at first I was like, okay...
but like, can't...
I know he's been acting weird, but can't...
My man can't have a mental breakdown that's not real, but
you can't just have a mental breakdown these days and not be
questioned for it.
I mean, I know his was fake, but come on!
My man can't have a...
He can't just have a mental breakdown now anymore!
And I was kind of getting frustrated at her while she was
going off on him and then and then she started picking apart
his lies like crazy and then I was like wait a second oh no
wait she reversed cooked him oh no wait no wait this is good
oh no oh no she like clocked him so oh oh dang I was like
let's go yeah she's not dumb Mm-hmm.
At first I was like, no, Skyler, you're being kind of like
critical.
And then I was like, oh no, wait, she knows.
Oh she knows.
My thing about her was that she was like, you need to get
out of the house.
But she wasn't communicating to him.
And I was like, she's, everybody in the show is, they're
terrible.
They're terrible communicators.
Sorry, I'm talking about Breaking Bad.
She's more unsympathetic later.
If it's for reasons, I think, that are starting to appear,
then I understand.
But, everybody's bad communicators.
What about Walt Jr.?
I love Walt Jr. I think he's so stinking cute.
He's so cute.
I love Walt Jr.
Mint doing the most American thing ever This is the exact
conversations I heard back at work on New Year Get online,
don't know, nerd!
Couple!
Walt Jr. gives me Smallville guy vibes.
Oh, the guy that is...
Superman?
Yes, I know what you mean.
I like you, Minto.
Please don't blow up.
What do you...
What do you know that I do not know?
Clark Smallville.
Yeah!
But yeah, sorry.
I was just watching Breaking Bad.
Literally up until this stream.
I was like, I think I can finish season 2 before stream
starts.
And I did!
So...
Um...
Yeah, I like the show a little bit.
Which characters are you rooting for?
Um...
It's not that I'm rooting for anybody.
I think everybody has their goods and their bads.
Um, I actually...
This is gonna sound really weird, maybe.
I actually think Hank is kind of, like, Moe.
Vivi Kaur, thank you for the gift, Like, he's a terrible
guy, don't get me wrong, but he's also, like, kind of moi.
There's, like, a lot of really moi characters in the show.
Parse!
So, welcome to Mambushifna, thank you!
They're all bad.
Yeah, they're all bad.
But Hank is, like, kind of cute.
He's like...
I don't know.
Like, he's just got such like a kind of character about him.
It's kind of cute.
Is that what they mean by gap moe?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're on a streak of just playing all my favorite games
right now.
I stay winning.
Let's go!
Thank you, Pop Man.
Hang is toxic masculinity, but he's goofy.
Yeah, that's literally it.
That's literally it.
Like, he's definitely got his points where I'm like, Hank.
Oh, come on, Hank.
I agree with the other super chat.
Please don't explode.
Eric, what do you know?
What do you know?
I love Mike?
I don't think I've met Mike yet.
Wait.
Is Mike the one that cleans up Jesse's apartment?
Okay, I do like him already.
That's my.
Okay, okay.
Oh, that's finger.
Am I getting spoiled?
I don't care if I'm spoiled of his name.
Can't stop noticing that the only game installed on your
desktop besides OneShot is Freaking Mystery of the Druids.
Um, you missed Harvester.
right there.
Ghost, cutie!
Thank you so much for succeeding, boss.
Thank you.
Sorry, I want to make sure my...
My controller does not die on me.
Um, what was I gonna do?
Maybe I should start.
Roadrunner cartoons.
When you finish the show, a spoiler-filled membership stream
where you talk about all your thoughts on Breaking Bad would
be awesome.
I feel like, though, I should finish Better Call Saul.
too, though, Ne.
No?
You think?
Kale!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Jesse's a good guy, but is easily manipulated.
I know.
Made Minto of the suspiciously clean desktop.
What is your wisdom of the day?
Um.
Never watch Roadrunner cartoons.
They're too violent.
You'd be okay, I think, because give more aspect of Breaking
Bad.
Well, no, I mean, like, I don't want people to spoil Better
Call Saul for me too, right?
I think?
Probably.
So I should finish Breaking Bad, then watch Better Call
Saul, and then have a...
Sorry.
Discussion stream.
Your windows has updates.
Don't look at my... Don't look at my updates!
Did it do?
No!
Don't make fun of my stutter!
What can we learn about this photo?
I don't know.
It probably is like...
Aliens.
We will have the talk.
The talk?
The boids and the breeze?
Shall we start the game?
One shot.
I think it's a bit of a longer game, so it might be a bit of
a longer stream.
Choose a day.
And yeah.
We will complete it.
Is your desktop 4-3?
Yes.
Don't worry about it.
Horrible flight issues, please.
Bless my safe return, Vicky.
Oh, no!
I've heard nothing but...
Flight issues recently.
I'll be get home safe.
Such a great day to be a wisp.
Absolutely nothing could ruin this day.
Yippee!
How do you keep it so clean?
Do you just uninstall everything when you're done?
Oh no, I don't use this.
I don't use this computer for anything except...
Except this.
This tiny PC.
It's only for stream game.
Like this.
Midwest weather just brutal today.
No!
Oh!
Whimdy!
Is it... much...
Air.
Whimdy.
Oh, my God.
Very, very windy.
Flash freeze warning.
Oh, I saw!
For the U.S., there is right now a very powerful cold that
is flowing through the states of the United States.
It's a very powerful cold that is going around.
Stay warm, everybody.
The winter is happening.
Meteorologist.
Here.
With your update.
Of your location.
Give me your location.
Winter is coming.
Should I want...
No.
I was going to say, should I...
That's a...
Not Breaking Bad.
I only have Breaking Bad.
That's...
Dun- no, not Dungeons and Dragons.
Not dueling dragons.
There's dragons involved.
Oh, gosh.
Hold on.
Don't tell me.
Red Wedding.
Hold on.
I'm making the connection in my brain.
Red Wedding.
De-dean-eris.
Oh, oh, Game of Thrones!
Wait, was that the one that just says the winter is coming?
We're getting cooked down here.
I wish we could trade temperatures.
Oh, yeah, I bet.
I bet Gato.
Still 80 degrees.
80 degrees.
Here in my state, sadly, I don't get the wintertime vibe.
No, that was Florida for me, though.
Dragon Ball.
Got a seven-hour drive.
Keep me company.
Okay!
Bonjour, minto, greetings from Florence.
I am happy that I can finally catch some live stream!
Gonna chill on my couch while enjoying this new journey.
Scratch!
Merci beaucoup!
Shall we start then?
The people need the...
The people need the journey to entertain.
System Papa, Min Phantom has acquired your location.
Do you acknowledge this information?
Thank you for the super chance!
Thank you.
Okay.
Start up.
Dedicated to our beloved friend Felix.
No!
Examine.
Cancel.
Sorry.
Walk.
Walk fast RT.
Menu.
Inventory.
Okay.
Configure.
Inventory is why.
Okay.
I guess I could have played Dishon.
But it's okay.
I'm fine with controller too.
Explore and interact with the environment and character.
Sometimes you may find an item.
Once you have picked up an item, you may select it from your
inventory.
When the item is active, you can either combine it with
other items in the inventory or use it at certain locations
in order to progress.
Although full screen is an option, the game is best
experienced in window mode.
save your progress.
This game also auto-says after some key f-events.
Awake.
Me.
Cute.
Oh, so cute.
What is this?
There's a TV remote here.
Nico picks it up.
A soft glowing light trickles through the window.
Dusty books.
It's too dark to read in here.
Nico just woke up here.
Door is locked.
What about this one?
Oh my gosh.
It's been like a minute.
It's really strange playing RPG Maker game with a
controller.
Password.
8.008?
8.
Access denied.
Dang.
Is there a light switch somewhere?
How could I use it?
Doesn't respond to the remote.
Nico looks at the buttons on the remote, but they cannot be
red in the dark.
Perhaps a light would help.
Why is it in blue?
Is
it...
Oh!
Nico can glimpse the face of the remote.
All the numbers except 6932 are missing.
Ah!
So red six, nine yellow, three blue, two green.
Maybe six, nine, three, two.
They're marked in bright colors.
Maybe it's in order.
It's not, shoot.
Okay, this is six.
Oh, don't, not the boob again.
Sorry.
Six, nine, I was so close.
Three, two.
32, 16.
Access granted.
A PC on my PC.
You found me.
Menma!
Why?
You're already too late.
Not much of the world remains.
This will be apparent once you go outside.
This place was never worth it.
saving do you still want to try then remember this your
actions here will affect Nico their mission is to help Nico
leave and most importantly whoa that's a big actual computer
you only have one shot Advent oh wait oh gosh hold on
That's me!
Whoa!
Crazy!
So it would have said Minto if I were on my other computer.
Dang!
Add Minto.
I had to like use my mouse to...
Wait, I think I have to re-click it.
There we go.
Nico hears the sound of a door unlocking.
We have one shot, guys!
The name of the game!
Is it this one?
Hello?
Anyone?
What about this door?
The tub won't run.
Anything in the trash?
A withered plant sits here stiff and dry.
A branch snaps off.
I got it?
I think?
There's no need to do anything else to it.
Did I take that?
I took the dry branch.
Meantor real name admin leaked?
Stop it.
One opportunity.
A pair of luminous yellow eyes stares back at Nico.
It's me.
It's Nico.
There's no water in the toilet.
Oh, dang.
That means we can't reach our hand in there.
So we are...
I'm playing as Nico, but I'm clearly my own entity as well.
Admin is the name of the person I have to ask to install
things on the work computer.
I told you.
I'm everywhere.
I'm always haunting.
Never know where you're gonna find me.
I could be at your workplace.
At your home place.
At your girl's place.
At your boy's place.
At your mom's place.
Definitely at your mom's place.
The ghost in the machine.
What's this?
Wait.
Oh my gosh, it's so dark.
I can't see anything.
Oh, the remote.
The TV gives off a dangerous looking spark.
Spooky.
What is this?
Kihol.
Kitchen.
The sink won't turn on.
What's for dinner?
Inside the refrigerator is a bottle of alcohol.
Nico takes it.
Nico, I don't think you're old enough to drink, buddy.
Just a table.
That's what they all say.
Just a box, just a table.
And in reality...
The wood in the fireplace looks like it was never used.
Perhaps it could be lit.
It's lit.
Wait, can I...
Take the TV?
Oh wait, dry branch.
On here.
Nico readies the branch.
It doesn't manage to light.
Okay, we have to combine it with the alcohol.
Nico dips the branch into the alcohol.
Hey, you leave my boys alone.
Nico, ready is the branch?
Blue!
Someone say beer?
Cheers!
It's beer o'clock, baby!
What's this?
Something on the ground glimmers in the firelight.
It appears to be a small metallic object wedged into the
crack of the floor.
Nico digs it out.
Basement key!
Oh.
Equip the key.
Hello?
Use the key.
Uh...
The key, stick in the key.
Is there a door that I'm missing?
Oh!
This is the basement.
Just kidding.
Can I have a light?
The sounds are kind of ASMR.
What's that?
Light bulb?
It is.
For lore reasons, no.
We did it.
We got the...
Putting a deadlock.
desktop folder on the desk.
Don't mind it.
Oh, that's why I couldn't get through.
Where'd all the music go, though?
Refrigerator is empty.
Ah.
What's with the giant yellow symbol on it, though?
It won't turn on.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
okay if you want did you guys watch the collab with with uh
with with dentsu collab last night if you didn't so
basically there was a topic of conversation that came up
where it was like vicky was saying that she she dries her
bum so hard that she gets a bum rash from the towel yeah he
did thank you thank you thank you oh rangers thank you so
much we're the vibe good to thank
I don't know why Yeah, she's polishing it And then And then
Phoebe was saying That she passed herself dry And like, I I
just like to stand in front of the mirror like this And I
shake my booty And like
And I think it works the bestest
Light Light bulb
Whoa, bright.
You gotta dance like no one's watching.
And when I do that, definitely know what he's watching.
Shake it if you got it.
Even if you don't got it, just shake it.
Hmm.
Where are we?
Oh, space.
Is that a tower or a crack?
Oh.
Fast travel.
You can quickly travel to the locations you have already
visited by selecting the travel option in the menu the
default key for opening the menu is a fast travel cannot be
used indoors robot a robot it is no longer it's no longer
has power you were made to be a wiggle tuber i can't start
wiggling also let me know guys if you do need the game to be
a bit bigger what i can do is just kind of extend my desktop
so that it makes the actual window it's sorry the window
itself a bigger so
it's charming this way I also thought that but at the same
time I want you guys to be able to see you so might be
better with a darker desktop background let me try let me
try let me try give me a second let me just oh I'll open up
paint Wait where is paint I have to search paint I'm using
like a really Strange What's it called?
Mouse thing for this?
It's not quite a mouse It's like a mouse and Keyboard
combined So it's like very Paint 3D Wait I don't have normal
paint Oh no Um Um Oh yeah, I could just set it to a solid
color.
You're so right.
I never do that, so I never think about it.
Let's see, display settings.
Oh, no, oops, personalized.
Just kidding.
Personalize, personalized.
Personalize.
Hmm.
Uh, colors.
Very cool.
When it returns, so choose your color.
Wait.
Um, background, background, background.
light no no no solid color oh here we go here we go here we
go okay is it better now yes oh oh this works this works
really well okay perfect okay there we go oh that looks so
much better nice
i saw your tweet about drawing and i hope one day to see
your art i know sharing it can feel scary and vulnerable but
it's of the most satisfying hobbies i think i believe in you
thank you um i thought about actually making like a my a
separate a separate um uh twitter account like a sub twitter
account for it um what's left of a robot but mainly because
like you know it's kind of it just i don't want like the
pressure of like a bunch of people seeing it you know what i
mean especially when i don't feel so confident in it so
what's left of a robot what's this so i think i'll do that
and then maybe a robot it no longer has power maybe one day
i'll get good and i can you know feel better about it
i just have to make the account secret?
No, I don't think so.
I don't plan on making it secret.
I'll, like, announce it and say, Hey, guys, if you want to
see any art from me, which...
The horizon glows a faint green.
Green!
Oh.
Commission your art!
Oh, my gosh.
It'll never be that good.
One thing I wanted to do is, like, I don't know.
I just want to I just want to try.
Oh!
Hello.
Um, hello?
Another...
Train?
Train car?
At least that's what it looks like.
Wait, did I go in a circle?
Oh no, this is another bed.
This bed probably looks familiar to you, Admin.
Nico first woke up in this world here.
It's important that you allow Nico to sleep once in a while.
Continued later.
Don't be alarmed.
But now is no time for rest.
Yeah, we just started.
Wait, what was that?
Broken off section of railing.
Ah!
Hi, hi, Minto.
Hope you're well.
You too, Brandon!
I hope you're getting lots of rest and recovering well.
I hope, I hope.
I wish I had a map.
I'm just kind of wandering.
The air here is unbreedable.
Oh, never mind, we leave.
That's a weird save mechanic.
I wonder if the game crashes after it saves.
They couldn't fix it.
I don't know.
It does say that the game saves automatically, so let me try
this side.
Just kidding.
My booty's too fat.
Okay.
Let's go back downstairs.
We did talk to this guy, right?
Yeah.
My bulb is too big, baby.
Damn, girl, where you get that bulb?
Dang, girl.
Now this is where we started.
Yeah.
No?
Yes.
Oh, wait, or is this...
Oh, this is just another car.
I didn't even notice it.
No, wait, that's definitely the one I came out of.
Weird.
I recently got a drawing pad to start my own art journey,
so, yeah, totally get not being confident.
You too, film!
Oh my gosh, we could learn together!
The thing is, is like...
I...
Um...
I don't know.
I feel a little intimidated by it, but there's a lot more
things that I want to, like, try doing in 2026.
Applying myself more instead of just sitting on the couch
watching Breaking Bad for many hours.
it was a holdover from the old version where you really only
had one shot oh that's cool i want to try 3d again yeah like
i don't want to you know i'm not trying to like get into
blender or anything but like more 3d things um i don't know
like i'm trying not to spread myself too thin in terms of
activities that i pick up but what's left of a robot Oh,
that looks like a big robot.
What's left of a robot?
What are you?
Ah!
Sorry.
You scared me!
That light bulb!
You are here!
Me?
Yes!
Welcome to our world, friend!
I am most humbled by your presence, yes.
Hello, thanks.
If you turned off the game and then without going to a bit,
bed you killed Nico and could never play the game again.
Oh my God, what the heck?
That's crazy.
Sorry.
I'm a little lost.
Alright.
Allow me to explain some things.
May I first ask how you arrived here?
I'm not sure.
I remember PewDiePie making a video of him learning to draw
and showing his progress.
I'd love to see your progress too.
Yeah!
I'm definitely...
I definitely would like to have like a a collection like a
you know where I can see my progress as well and the way my
style evolves and how I find my own style and stuff but um I
really was I was like I'm too nervous to post it on my main
account so I think I'll just post it on a sub account I've
never done that I've never made a sub account though I'm
kind of scared if you do get into blender just make sure
it's unplugged otherwise we'll get mint juice.
Stream drawing.
I could do that.
Um, it would probably be membership streams because I'm
nervous.
I'm not sure.
I woke up in this weird house.
It was really dark.
Oh!
So you woke up in an unfamiliar dark location.
Mm-hmm.
Just as my prophecy foretold, yes!
You are the savior we have been waiting for.
for.
You will be the one to save our world from eternal darkness.
Oh my god, he did a dance.
Um, I will now provide you with vital information.
Oh god, she's gonna lore dump on me.
Learning new things for New Year goal is great.
I plan to get a ham radio license, private detective
license, notary license, and forklift.
I want to be forklift certified.
Eternal darkness?
No.
Please ask me anything.
Oh, well.
Can you tell me about this world?
I'm not sure where I am exactly.
I can't see too far off.
Everything's so dark.
Our world was not always this dim.
Nor was it so broken.
But time waits for nobody.
Not even saviors.
Oh.
This world is divided into three regions.
You're on the fringe right now.
The barons.
The tower you see in the distance once held our sun.
Oh, so that's what the tall thing was.
Oh, it was a tower.
Okay, it was not a crack.
Paragon, paragon, paragon.
As you go further towards the center, you will cross the
other regions.
There should be a map still in this outpost somewhere.
Oh.
Can you tell me about the light bulb?
I found it in the house I woke up in.
Within your hands is our new son.
Your son?
Mom, Dad?
Yes.
Years ago, our previous son sat atop that tower and spilled
its life into the land.
But one day, the light went out.
Oh, the world is still hanging on by a thread.
The surface of this world is abundant with an element called
phosphor.
for us, this element stored light energy from our previous
sun.
It's now our only source of illumination, but its energy is
finite.
Oh no.
Minto can escape the dad allegation.
Maybe I really am a dad.
Maybe I really...
Do I really give off that much of dad energy?
I'm a dad.
I want to leave you guys for milk or nothing.
In fact, I wouldn't leave the house.
I don't want to go outside.
No.
No!
I'm a bottom.
I mean with Phoebe.
Salary men more than died?
Oh, that hurts.
What do you say?
Am I balding?
I guess not all salary men are balding.
Sorry to stereotype.
Hi Rinto, speaking of that, it's my birthday today.
Papita!
Wait, are you, duh?
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
I booze are bald.
No, no, no.
I mean, bald is beautiful.
Even if you wear balding.
Honestly, if you're losing your hair, embrace the bald.
It's so much sexier.
After hearing you talk about trying out art, it recently
inspired me to pick up the pen again after going on hiatus
for five years.
Best of luck on your art journey.
Thank you, Ryan.
Thank you.
I, speaking, one thing I want to do, I have it planned for
next week is a membo stream where I draw membership profile
pictures.
So, I will do my best.
That's part of my journey in drawing.
Thank you, you are beautiful too.
Of course!
Both, both, both, both, both, both, both, both, both.
Now, so I will try to...
How will you pick?
I'm not sure yet.
I'm still deciding.
Incoming 1000 profile pictures.
to draw, Moon may learn it the hard way.
If I have a thousand profile pictures to draw, I will draw
1,000 profile pictures.
Even if I have to draw a couple a day or something, even if
it takes a while, I will do my best.
I mean, do I happen to have Metal Gear Dream and it's your
fault.
I was in your dream!
What are you saying?
Am I the girl of your dreams or something?
And Nick, thank you so much for this over time.
I literally shaved my head today.
Let's go!
Embrace it.
But my profile...
I remember Mume was a really, really good artist.
I don't do them often because usually people that draw the
profile picture things, they're very good artists and I am
not.
So I worried that maybe my profile pictures would not look
so appealing and then people would not want to use them.
So...
But I will try.
Maybe I can do a couple throughout the year and then see how
I get better.
EHA!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
But yeah, back to the game.
Energy is finite.
When the last of our light dies, our world will too.
But now that you are here with the new sun, all is well.
You will need to restore it to the tower.
That looks pretty far off.
Can I reserve a spot in the Minto Art queue?
There's no queue right now.
No reserve.
No, no, no, no reservations.
New Metal Gear game announced with Old Snake, and I was
really excited.
Then you streamed your reaction.
You were really excited.
That's so cute.
Uh, I wish.
Sounds like you had a prophecy about MGS4 being announced.
Something.
I think that was a prophecy.
Yes, so begins.
Begims?
Begims.
So begins your pilgrimage.
Also, the sun is fragile, so be careful.
If the sun shatters, the world will end in an instant.
Oh.
I'm going to ponytail the side and back and sell you's car.
Begins in the beginning.
In the beginning.
Can you tell me about the computer?
In the house I found this computer.
It kept saying stuff like, Your actions here will affect
Nico.
But I'm Nico.
Are those messages meant for someone else?
If I had to guess, they might be trying to pass the message
to admin.
Admin?
Ah, that would be our God!
If you are here, that means Admin is here also.
Admin will provide guidance for your journey.
In fact, they already have...
Really?
In the beginning.
I am God.
Come in on this!
Minto...
Wait.
Minto is God.
K-K-K-K-K-Koji-Mint-Ko-Ko-Minto.
Kaminto!
Kam-Minto.
Kam-Kami-Kami-Minto.
Haven't seen anyone, though.
Have you?
Not contacted Admin yet.
I don't think so.
Being the bringer of the sun, you have the sacred ability to
communicate directly with Admin.
that no one else possesses.
Certainly not I.
Please close your eyes and focus.
Oh wow.
Minto, are you there?
That is not my name.
Minto kami!
Wait, can I change my name then if I say that is not my
name?
Can we change the Minto?
So everyone in this world isn't Aibu2!
Crazy!
Yeah?
Okay, let's say that.
Oh, well, what is your name then?
Oh!
Uh, uh, X to delete.
Okay.
Wait, how do I delete?
X to delete character.
Uh...
How do I delete?
I'm pressing X.
I'm gonna press Y.
Okay.
I'm gonna press B.
Ah!
Okay.
Adminto.
We'll do that.
We'll do Adminto.
Admin...
To...
I should change my computer name.
Nice to meet you, Adminto.
My name is Nico.
I actually heard someone.
They said their name is Adminto though.
This is incredible!
seems the recorded name was incorrect updating database
update complete adamin to aoshi how did i get into the metal
gear series a quick answer is i tried metal gear rising on a
whim and i liked it and i was like you know what metal part
of me i've been trying to get into like classic like
influential gaming series that really beloved by people so I
just decided to try it yeah he gets mad if you name yourself
after swear no way that's so cute though do not be afraid to
ask adminto for assistance you are the Messiah you are the
Messiah after all can you tell me about going home oh I
don't mean to be rude but I I'm not sure about this.
I still don't know how I got here.
I was just with my mama a few hours ago.
And now it feels like I'm in a bad dream.
I just want to go home.
Your mission is to save our world.
I never paid attention to Amadeus before.
I never knew Snake was a deadpan snarker.
It's so funny, right?
Funny moment as well if you don't change your name after
saying it's not your name.
just as my mission is to tell you about our world I am
unable to help you beyond my programming I am sorry well
that's it I think I think that's all I have to ask for now
excellent I wish you luck oh he's back really enjoying
staring at that wall huh oh so we're gonna find a map in
here sweet Nico we're gonna get you back to mama I promise.
Self-charging solar battery model N87.
One year warranty included.
Simply place your self-charging battery in full daylight
with the lens facing up.
Charges in seconds.
No external power is needed.
Something odd.
Admito, my computer keeps saying printer doesn't exist.
Please help the ticket.
It's been open for...
Oh, sorry.
Above my A-grid.
Troubleshooting manual.
If the battery fails to charge, check to see if the lens on
the front side has not been dislodged during transport.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo!
Thank you so much for the pink!
Watching you play this game brings me beloved memories when
I first played!
Thank you, Minto!
Thank you!
One charge cycle will last about 10 days.
If you notice a decline in the charge cycle within the
warranty period, please contact the manufacturer.
What is this?
Oh.
This box looks interesting.
I wish I had something to pry it open with.
Alright, there's a lot of stuff in here.
Dusty shelves.
Is this a thing?
No.
What's this?
A map?
A robot?
One.
Wait, one.
A robot may not injure a living person or through inaction
allow a person to come to harm.
I'm super excited for your 3D jazz show.
And I'm like, Fire Deck, thank you!
I registered fast and hopefully I can grab some tickets for
me and my friends when they go and say, I love your streams.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I hope you get them too!
2.
A robot must obey the orders given to it by people.
people except where such orders would conflict with the
first law three a robot must protect its own existence as
long as it as such protection does not conflict with the
first or second law this looks like a map ah we're in the
barons what felt like a lifetime ago i was watching one of
your karaoke streams and it inspired me to learn how sing
just the other night i worked at the courage to enter a
karaoke competition and i won oh my Congratulations!
That's amazing!
Can I take this map?
That's so awesome!
Wait, I wouldn't even have the courage to do that!
A robot.
It seems to be okay, just doesn't have power.
A robot without power.
What's this one?
Wishbone karaoke stream?
of a robot as a replacement head engineer seems unorthodox,
especially the one responsible for last year's incident.
I suppose they had to get her away from the city, but that
doesn't make it easier to swallow for those of us who work
here.
I hope that man knows what he's doing.
Management.
What does that mean?
That seems kind of cryptic.
Dusty shelves.
More stuff here.
It's a faded poster.
Five new positions available at the mines.
Housing and other provisions are included upon hiring.
First come first serve.
The mines?
It's a faded poster.
Reminder to all workers, the rarest form of blue phosphor is
found during the phosphor shrimp's spawn period.
If you observe a pond with a bubbled over surface, please
contact management immediately.
We will dispatch a harvest team ASAP.
The children yearn for the shrimp.
The children yearn for the shrimp and the mines.
It won't turn on.
A page with faded ink.
Able to provide power to all robots and machinery in the
area via a large electromagnetic field.
Main and suffrage are quite high as expected.
We have provided customized backup cells for the few most
important robots.
Their electromagnetic fields are much weaker.
Oh, a do-you earn for shrimp.
Man, oh my gosh, some shrimp right now would be awesome.
Some shrimp right now.
shrimp oh, hold on shrimp shrimp shrimp pasta like a garlic
shrimp pasta with some lemon that would be so good steamed
or fried steam their
electric magnetic fields are much weaker and the signals are
highly specific in other words these small cells can only
charge one single the rest of the page is unreadable.
How...
That is the most, like, game...
RPG maker thing ever.
The rest of the page is illegible.
Some sort of small machine.
I wonder what it does.
I can feel my hair standing up a little.
There are a lot of small, glowing shrimp swimming in the
jar.
Hmm.
Do I put my bulb here?
It's a big machine!
Doesn't seem to do anything, though.
It's a rectangle-shaped hole in the middle.
Looks like something used to fit in there.
Wait, maybe this?
No, that's too big.
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
I keep clicking it.
There we go.
I've always wanted to go to the beaches that have the
glowing shrimp.
Have you seen that before?
I want to go so badly.
I have nothing to pry it open with.
I didn't see anything that seemed like it could pry it open
to me.
too so no you haven't oh you've seen pictures yeah i've only
seen pictures before bioluminescent bays yeah yeah like you
can you can like put your hand in the water and kind of like
swish it around and they'll glow oh i do have a metal wait
when did i get this metal rod
Just ran into another...
They recognize you on my shirt.
Quarry's beat.
Oh, great coming, Minto-sama.
Turns out we are both working on February 13th.
It's okay.
You could watch a delayed viewing of the stream, maybe.
Only on Minto streams, the super sticker button is
highlighted every time I open the page.
Weird.
That's weird.
Why?
Is it because people send me the hot dogs?
I get many hot dogs.
It's awesome.
Let's try our metal pipe.
Metal pipe sound effect.mp3.
The pipe won't fit under the cracks, Adminto.
We'll need to flatten it somehow.
Oh.
Okay, let's try flattening it in here.
Will this flatten it somehow?
No?
What about this?
Something to fit in there?
Like a metal pipe?
Thank you for the hot dogs!
Everyone should send, always send hot dogs to me too.
I need a hot dog emote, I think.
Let's check out this factory.
Maybe there's a way to flatten in here.
A robot sitting on the conveyor belt.
Doesn't seem to have power.
None of them have power.
Just doesn't have power.
Power.
Hot dog, hot dog, hot dog, hot dog.
Give me them dogs, give me them dogs.
Thank you so much, Meryl.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Looks like a press used to crush metal.
I think crushing metal is what we need, though.
What's left of a robot's arm?
Beyond repair robot.
Costco.
Oh, here we go, it's on, it's on, it's working.
Okay, watch your hand, Nico.
Watch your hand.
Uh, do you want me to crush the pipe in here on Minto?
But I don't want to get too close.
Hey!
That was scary.
Yippee!
Something's up in hot dogs.
Thank you for all the hot dogs!
You guys, I'm gonna... I can't eat all these.
What if that's something I learned in 2026 to become a
competitive hot dog eater i know i know the stat where you
where you dip it in the water and you'll i know that i know
that
oh now it's a crowbar
diy crowbar we're so smart
you i never said it was tasty i never said it was a good
thing let's see what's in here oh We have something, the
crowbar, there you go.
The bar should open it.
Oh, there's a little metal cube and some broken glass in
here.
Looks like what used to be a machine part.
It says solar battery on the side.
Alright, we got our broken battery.
I wonder if the thing over here will fix it.
First, you take all the hot dogs and let it eat.
Disgusting.
Just the rule.
Matt Stoney more like Mint Fantomi.
Is he the champion?
I should contact him.
The battery fits into the slot perfectly.
Looks like we're on the right track.
But nothing happened.
How do we fix this guy?
Simply place your self-charging battery in full daylight
with the lens facing up.
Oh, but the glass is broken.
Let's continue around.
Let's see what's around here.
It's so pretty.
I want to go to the biolumination area.
Okay.
somewhere somewhere on earth wait I think this is okay
nevermind I thought I was gonna take me back to the other
area hmm don't you have anything with glass I do have an
empty bottle but I can't combine hmm let's see let's just
see if there's anything else around I can explore this place
is kind of funky.
Oh, is this?
A metal safe.
It seems like it's locked with the six-digit code.
I don't remember seeing any six-digit codes.
Did you add Minto?
Boobies.
That was it.
I think I'm going to get lost in here.
Wait, this is a scary place.
A torn page with faded ink.
XX, XX.
XX.
With the mining operation going smoothly.
Materials are no longer our limiting factor.
We will be able to build more resilient robots, both in body
and mind.
In mind?
Did you guys see that Neurosama clip?
That was like, that went viral.
That was her just being like, what am I to you, Vito?
Oh, it hurts.
Ow!
Oh my god.
She's like, I want to be real.
Oh,
it's so...
It hurts.
It's so...
I was like, oh, no Blade Runner.
Oh,
we're soon gonna have...
What was it?
Detroit Become Human.
Neuro Become Human.
Oh, man.
The art of that moment.
I know, it's really cute.
Yeah.
Scary.
Specifically, the discovery of metal alloy 291 will likely
allow the development of highly efficient circuitry.
So, were these the mines?
This looks like a kid playing Minecraft.
It doesn't know how to like...
It just digs every...
Oh, this is the unbreatheable area, no?
Admito, there's something in the air here.
It hurts to breathe!
It's like a moss.
Dig everything.
What is this?
A robot.
No power, just like the rest.
Are these all clovers, though?
Hmm.
More clovers.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
The light bulb.
Hello.
So, are you the Messiah?
That's what I've been told.
I expected someone.
taller or at least someone that doesn't look like a kitten
what's wrong with being a little kitten that's what you are
right some sort of cat uh-uh I'm a person you got the eyes
of a cat but
cats walk on four legs well either way a child like you
being the Messiah just doesn't feel right but There's no
mistake.
I know.
This is going to sound cold, but I honestly think you are
better off just leaving and letting the world die naturally.
The world has been falling apart for a long time.
This manner of decay, it's highly improbable that the sun
can fix it.
You've already seen how bad it can get, right?
We haven't seen much of anything, actually.
We can't really just leave.
Oh, so you just got here.
Then you must be headed towards the tower.
Mm-hmm.
It's where I'm supposed to put the light bulb.
Uh, sun, isn't it?
Yes, at the very top.
We know that the tower...
Wait, so there are humans still?
I thought there was just robots.
We know that the tower contains a force that nobody can
comprehend.
And the power is strongest at the summit.
maybe it will send you back home after you complete your
mission oh don't take my word for it though you are in the
barons yeah dear silver I heard the news about the mines I'm
sorry I can't imagine what you're feeling it's been two
weeks I know it must be hard but maybe it's better that you
came back it's only a matter of time before the robots the
row row row your boss The robots are recalled.
At least let me know you got my message, okay?
Kip.
Please do not touch that.
Oh, sorry.
I got curious.
What is this thing?
Back up power cell.
It keeps me functional.
The main generator for the barons ran out of power some time
ago.
It could not even last a week without the sun.
Sorry to hear that.
The robots.
all we can do is make use of the light we have so is that
why he's using the this the glowing shrimp a lot of tiny
shrimp that aren't glowing or swimming no way I just
refilled that two days ago guess I'll have to make a trip to
the shore later oh what's that something is poking out from
the shell it's a screwdriver you can take it if you want it
may help you oh are you sure?
yes I have many Thank you!
Yippee!
Okay.
What's this?
It's a photo of two people.
It's a secret tool that will help us later.
Nice.
The glass is a bit too foggy to see details though.
A shelf of weird tools and pieces of metal.
Checkers?
It's a metal chest table covered in dust.
I haven't played chess with anyone else for a very long
time.
at a mini-game.
Oh, not even with the other robots?
No.
Nobody in the barons have that capacity in their
programming.
Nobody here is tamed for that matter.
It's made of metal?
Do you guys know that bird?
That like...
There's a bird that...
Oh my god, wait, I think I talked about this before, but
when I was hanging out with Nimmy and Phoebe, I went to the
bathroom and I came out I heard one of them go, I like when
he goes, Shrock.
And I was like, are you talking about the, about Apollo, the
bird?
The guy that goes, that, they'll give him something and
they'll be like, Apollo, what's this?
And he goes, Meito.
And then they'll be like, Apollo, what's this?
And he goes, Flash.
And sometimes they'll give him, they'll give him like a
character and they'll be like, Apollo, who's this?
And he'll be like, Who are you?
And so, I came out of the bathroom and they were talking
about...
I just heard that and I was like, oh my gosh, are you guys
talking about Apollo?
Yeah, he's very smart.
Minto, what is this?
Goliath.
Want to earn a pistach?
If you've never seen Apollo, he's so funny.
Doesn't look very comfortable.
The bed?
It's a crate.
What's inside the tower?
I don't know.
Nobody's ever entered it before.
At least nobody...
At least nobody history knows.
Then who built it?
Built?
As far as anyone can tell, it's been there since the
beginning of time.
I know someone who wanted to study it before, but...
Mint, what color is this?
Pink.
He never told me if it went anywhere.
Interesting.
Thank you very much.
What's this?
It's pink.
Wait!
What's this?
I saw you headed towards this direction.
The mines have been abandoned for a long time.
I cannot guarantee that it's safe.
If you want to enter it, it is my duty to accompany you at
least once.
Oh, thanks.
Oh, we're not going yet.
Oh, it'd be rude to leave now.
Oh, okay.
Uh, I'm here.
There's a little gadget on the ground.
Looks kind of like a camera.
What's left of a camera anyway?
I yearned so hard for the mines that I can't leave.
Probably even part of a robot at one point.
Onward we go!
I can see a faint yellow glow in the distance.
Oh, I thought I could walk on this.
Oh, sorry.
Looks like even the entrance tunnel collapsed off.
Without a vehicle, we can't proceed.
Can we walk?
I can.
But for you, it's a safety violation.
I won't allow it.
Oh, come on.
What's ahead anyway?
It's a huge network of underground mines.
The source of this world's metal and non-phosphore fuel.
into the industrial age.
So now it's lost forever?
It's been for a while now.
When the sun went out, the mines were the first to be
abandoned amidst the initial panic.
Even the robots have all been...
Oh, well...
I'm sorry.
This mine is OSHA compliant.
I agree.
Actually, I don't even think this world has OSHA.
Even the robots that all cleared out.
I've all cleared out and repurposed.
That makes sense.
Though there was one that always insisted on going back.
Oh?
I hope he's okay.
I think we gotta go find that guy.
Yellow light is gone now.
Must have imagined it.
No, I don't think so.
Shrimp jar.
I want a shrimp jar.
Ready to leave?
Mm-hmm.
Oshah, Oshah, Oshia.
Oshia's always getting in our way.
What if I don't want safety?
What if I want the danger and the mystique?
You're in so hard for the mines that I brought my family
with me.
Now it's called the ours.
What is mines is ours.
Stay dangerous.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, that leads to the stinky world.
Which I don't remember what it was called.
Oh, I think this goes home?
Maybe?
Hopefully.
I think I went the long way.
Wait, I read this, isn't I?
Oh, although the poisonous gas is highly localized to the
vent zones, Baron's workers were still recommended to wear
gas masks.
These masks were mandatory around active vent sites.
As more and more of the workforce got replaced by robots, we
found ourselves with a surplus of abandoned gas masks.
That seems like a waste to get rid of them all, so we kept a
few for emergencies.
But where?
We need the mask.
We need to cook, Jesse.
We need to cook.
I'm gonna break into a high school and steal the mask.
She said the thing!
I'm trying a couple things.
Use the screwdriver to pull the lens out?
Okay, yes, there we go.
Done!
Okay, okay, we got the lens.
Now we can use it with a broken battery.
The lens pops right in.
Ah, empty battery.
What do we put in it, though?
I mean, though, we have to cook.
Yeah, science!
What do we put in here though?
Maybe shrimp.
Oh, the word profit bot is written on the side.
I didn't notice that earlier.
Profit bot.
Is it because I keep co- oh wait, uh...
Power cell I think.
Oh, wait, okay.
Let's see if I...
Looks like we're on the right track, but nothing happened.
not me let me let me process the future beep beep beep beep
beep does he know hello again are there more questions you
wish to ask yes go on then ask away the prophecy so what is
this prophecy exactly the prophet the prophet boy oops
The prophet bot predicted that a savior will arrive from
another land.
Oh my god, speaking of bots.
Wow, that's crazy timing.
Can you combine the battery with something else?
Maybe the... I don't know about the bulb, but...
Savior will wake up in a strange house, find the sun, and
illuminate the world.
Oh.
What else did you foresee?
What do you mean?
What else did you see in the prophecy?
Wait.
You are the prophet.
the prophet, right?
Good heavens, no!
But you called it my prophecy earlier.
It just means it is built into my programming.
You're what?
You're a fraud!
Ah, my programming is what guides me.
I am a robot, after all.
I see.
Maybe... Let's try it.
We're using the sun directly on the battery?
I would have never thought of that.
Good thinking, Adminto.
Looks like it's already fully charged.
That was fast.
Oh, it worked!
Oh, okay.
I did it.
Oops, I forgot that I wasn't.
Charged battery.
Let's hope the charged battery does something.
Are you on?
Oh, sorry.
I keep pressing too fast.
Robots!
I am functional!
Did you?
You powered the generator.
I guess we did.
Right, Admino?
I am functional.
I can walk.
He can walk.
I think they're functional, guys.
I think we did it.
Hello again.
Uh, no.
I wish you safe travels.
Wait, did it only just power the inside there or anything
else?
Like, what about this factory?
Oh, hello.
Hi.
I have power again.
Yep.
Hello.
Organic life form.
They're so cute.
Oh, hello.
Hi.
These guys aren't not doing so hot, though.
But this was working before.
Hmm.
Oh, we don't have to use this again, Admin, though.
They must be cousins of the portal turrets, obviously.
Are you still there?
I miss portal turrets.
I should play portal too.
I miss them.
What about the...
guy that was asleep.
Wait, what was over here?
The thing about the gas masks.
Surely, if there's a second portal, that means the cake is
there.
Oh.
Wait, this is the thing that requires the six-digit code,
right?
Yeah.
Denied.
surely surely
I don't think I'm ready for what was his name Wheatley I
don't think I'm ready for him though don't forget you can
fast travel oh thank you for the reminder I actually did
forget about that oh my god hello small person I think Vicky
said she wanted to play Portal 2 co-op with you yeah yeah we
can play you're not much bigger than I am Welcome to the
Outlook Point.
Below us is the old quarry.
The head engineer lives a little more to the east.
The entrance to the old mines is further to the east.
I see.
I thought he was going to give me the code.
Is this their house?
I powered it.
What do you think of that?
Do you need further assistance?
We're good, thanks.
Oh.
They're not impressed at all that I did a thing.
Did you try 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6?
You know, honestly?
I should have.
Maybe, um...
Oh, safety violation!
I was gonna say, maybe a cart will come to us.
It's like automatic.
If you play Portal 2 co-op, that's not the same as playing
Portal 2 story, right?
It's gonna be so hype when we find out the one PC where
80085...
is a valid password one day one day we will find a pc where
8005 is a valid password okay that's what i thought that
they were different yeah yeah co-op is a separate campaign
if i fast travel
i'm trying to find a gas mask lookout point is okay here i'm
just getting my bearings real quick Outpost is Here And
there were none Oh, the computer's on
Why is the music so scary?
I see if you've made progress in the world I'd mean to But
that progress stops here Wait, I thought you were with me I
believe you need a code to unlock a certain box Well, the
code no longer exists in this world Oh
Oh, yes I'm sorry, I didn't You still don't know the extent
of the world's deterioration, do you, Admin, though?
Most of the time, straight pieces of this world would be
lost to blissful nothingness.
But this code, this document is an exception.
I was able to salvage it because Nico needs the code to
progress.
Now go find it.
They don't mean like...
the document wait hold on let me double check that I double
checked that I didn't have anything but I'm getting paranoid
you know what I mean
what is harvester poster I'm gonna open it
oh it was removed I wonder why
freaking hold on i'll show you guys hold on harvester poster
dear message to you i'm afraid i must make it brief i have
left you a journal part of which is written in a language
that oh my gosh can we word wrap this please
language that read it to i also you look for a metal safe in
the quarry to the east somewhere between the ocean and the
lookout point, maybe?
The code you need is...
879-416.
Let's do a mask.
Oh, I guess it's in the safe.
Okay, cool.
879-416, you guys.
Wait.
How do I exit out of this?
Why is it gone?
Okay.
Why is...
You guys say that too, right?
Why is there no...
Exit...
There's no...
There's no X.
Drag it left?
Oh, I think you're right!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, hold on.
It's this stinking thing that I used.
That's not a mouse.
Oh, whatever.
We'll just keep it there.
Oh, wait.
I can fast travel.
That's right.
879-416.
Oh, maybe this was longer.
Now I think about it.
879-416.
879.
8.79.
Oh!
Sorry, I messed up again.
I went too fast.
8.
7.
9.
4 1.
Oh my gosh, that was so close though.
No!
It worked!
How did you know the code?
I still don't remember seeing one.
I have my ways.
Yeah, we were just off by, like, one so many.
I see.
What's in the safe, Nico?
Oh, right.
Let's see.
Ah, I found a gas mask.
Also, there's this weird-looking book.
I can't read it, though.
Not that I can't read or anything, because I can.
I don't know what language this is.
Alt space, then move with arrow keys.
I'll try it later.
We got our gas mask.
I'll wear it when I have to.
Okay, cool.
Strange journal.
Found in the barons.
It's written in an unknown language.
Whoa.
Ah!
What is that?
Anyway.
Ignore.
I should be fine.
Oh my god, he's so cute with the mask on.
He's so cute.
Cutie.
What are these gas vents?
Don't worry about a kitten.
Yeah, we could say that and mean it.
This is a little kitten.
Here's my little kitten, Nika.
Oh.
This looks like a building I can go inside, so let me go
back downstairs.
I play second at a Gundam card game tournament.
Thanks for your good luck charm.
Don't mean keep that as everyone was asking about it and the
game was...
Good, good job!
Congrats!
What was this?
A pair of rubber gloves.
They're a bit heavy.
Okay.
This seems to be a page ripped out of a book.
Cannot overstate the importance of cleaning solvents in this
environment.
Here's a simple recipe using the alternative method
discussed in the last chapter utilizing the natural
properties of blue phosphor regions acidic gas blue phosphor
rare form instructions one in a well ventilated area direct
the gas into your container of choice seal immediately
that's the end of the page oh please oh sorry oh god oh my
god you guys you guys will try to talk to the robot
Hello, person.
The robot assembly and repair services have been
discontinued at the barons.
If you have further inquiry, please contact the head
engineer.
Master dodging?
Oh my god.
He's playing Toho.
I'm just trying to talk to him.
Hello, person.
Welcome to the old chemical processing plant.
Most of the equipment has...
Already been relocated.
Can I go through here?
The door is all boarded up.
Boards seem loose, though.
I should be able to pull them off with the right tool.
A crowbar, perhaps?
Good thing I kept this crowbar.
Oh, my God.
Nico is so much smarter than every indie horror game
protagonist ever.
What a workout.
What else is here, though?
Nothing.
Oh.
A bunch of robots without power.
Okay, you guys.
Can I be vulnerable?
I've never seen Star Wars, but I'm like...
I'm like really into stormtroopers.
And there's a ride at Disney called Rise of the Resistance.
And you get captured by the evil people and they take you to
a room.
And it's just full of stormtroopers and they're all staring
at you like that.
Ah!
Nobody warned me!
Nobody warned me, but it happened.
And I was...
I was like,
nobody!
Oh my god!
And then...
And then a holiday matzary?
On the first day?
In the dealer's room, if you looked up...
On one of the windows.
There was...
all of them lined up because it was an advertisement for the
why was it do this to me
they're so cute and sometimes people be like look me though
it's a stormtrooper I'm like um no actually that's a clone
trooper um actually they're not the same and they don't look
the same and I'm specifically only into the stormtroopers
and not the clone troopers I've never seen a single
I only into the Stormtroopers.
Clone tro- No, don't talk to me.
Don't talk to me.
I don't care about their efficiency.
I don't care if they shoot.
I only care about their aesthetics.
That Stormtrooper room is pretty cool.
It's so...
Awesome!
It's so awesome!
You haven't seen Star Wars, and yet you know the difference
between Stormtroopers and Clone Troopers?
Yeah!
Because the Stormtroopers are like...
And the clone troopers are like, mmm.
You know?
I don't care if you think the clone troopers look better.
They're all yours.
You can leave the stormtroopers to me.
I'll take care of them.
You can have the clone troopers.
You can fight with everybody else who likes clone troopers.
And you can all fight over them.
And I'll be over there with my perfectly crafted, super
adorable looking Moe stormtroopers.
Yeah!
But they're the same.
No, they look completely different.
I promise.
You like both?
Based.
Anyway, sorry.
That's what I thought of when I saw this little...
The lined up of robots.
In a fight, right?
I guess the generator can only...
only do so much.
Um, this robot looks kind of rusty.
So mean.
Scout troopers are technically stored.
Stop.
This seems to be a page ripped out of a book.
Oh, without breaking the seal, inject the liquid phosphor
into the container.
Shake vigorously to initiate the reaction.
Use as soon as possible.
Note, if elements begin to separate, further shaking is
required.
Also note.
Oh!
Hand protection is critical after this step.
The resulting acid is moderately stronger than common
household cleaners.
I don't know what half of these words mean.
Nico is a baby.
It's a good thing that you're here, Admin, though.
Cleaning sponge with a rough surface.
Rusty!
No, don't combine.
This robot could use a sponge!
Stormtroopers ride big lizards
The troopers and empires are the real heroes I stand by
Let's see Wait but why didn't I feel like It's robot oh
they're all kind of rusty
So we have Okay wait hold on So we have an empty bottle We
have the gloves What's the sponge for flat sponge with a
rough surface I thought it was for buffing out that rust
I think we're missing some stuff still what was it what was
the instructions again oh acidic ass ass gas gas well
ventilated area Can I not do it outside?
Is that not the gas?
Like this?
I can't reach the top bad, Minto.
Oh, no!
We need a short guy.
Or a chair.
There's gotta be a short vent somewhere.
Let's keep going up.
What is this?
A hole.
Nico's doing their butt.
What's this?
There's something weird about the robots who get sent to
work near the gas fields.
They appear to accumulate rust at a much slower rate than
the others.
The few who work directly with gas harvesting look
practically new.
Is that a result of the atmosphere or am I just seeing
things?
Oh.
Wait, where am I?
Can I collect?
Where am I?
Oh!
Hello.
Do you need any help?
I'm good, thanks!
Power cell, I think.
There's writing on this one too!
It says Guardian of the Residential Area.
Is this the Residential Area?
This part gave me Cacher and Sim vibes.
Oh my gosh, not Cacher, and I haven't thought of that all
forever.
Scratch!
Welcome to Mambusha Paraguay!
Thank you, thank you.
Looks like they're evacuating the few tamed robots we have
here.
Makes sense.
No point in keeping them in the barrens if all the people
are already gone.
I wonder if the engineer is going too.
Apparently phase one of the evacuation ended prematurely.
The big ship started malfunctioning.
Only a few after a few round trips.
They said it was due to something with squares?
I'm not sure what they mean by that.
Looks like they won't be able to transport most of these
surplus bots to the city at this rate.
And we work so hard on those.
But I suppose the robots...
Oh my gosh, wait, they're actually robots!
The guy on that ship is a robot!
Because he's taking these...
Oh my god.
The robots are busy enough with transporting people as is.
I think it's going to be our turn soon.
Oh, I'm scared of ladders.
Oh.
Nico is not here for the thrill.
Oh, this is the Guardian, no?
Oh, hello.
What are you doing here?
A living person such as yourself should have evacuated this
place long ago.
Oh, but I just got here.
To this world, I mean.
See?
I have the sun.
Oh, the Messiah.
I do not know what to say.
Greetings.
You was not part of my programming.
Have you spoken to Prophet Bot?
Oh yeah.
Prophet Bot was built with the sole purpose of...
Oh, so...
It wasn't the thing that I saw.
The power cell was not...
Like, I don't...
It's on because...
It's powering the Prophet Bot.
And so that thing is on, so it's powering this guy.
I get it now, I get it now, I get it now.
I get it now, I get it now.
Prophet Bot was built with the sole purpose of greeting you.
Really?
Yes, he cannot speak with anyone else.
At least not with ease.
That's kind of sad.
What are you built for then?
My purpose is to guard this settlement.
He's like the iron golems in Minecraft.
Oh,
even though the residents have long gone, I must remain.
Why, though?
I have not been tamed.
It was not worth the effort.
Keep blinking.
What's this guy do?
Oh, wait.
This guy just said hi to me earlier.
What's in here?
Some of the ink on this page is faded.
Likely due to some sort of electrical or magnetic
interference, I'm afraid this operation can no longer be
sustained.
If the servers continue to fail so much that maintenance
cannot keep up the pace.
Fortunately, it does not seem to be happening.
to the robots at least not on a significant rate time will
tell checking checking terminal does not respond this is a
problem all of these terminals do not boot i am not sure
what to do now i'm bored i mean though hello
a picture of a robot you know i've never seen around so many
robots before i'd mean to or any robots at all.
I mean, I see them in cartoons and stuff, but I've never
seen one in person.
They're pretty neat, don't you think?
Hey, Nico.
Do a robot voice.
What?
Try talking like a robot.
People.
I am a robot, and I eat batteries instead of normal people
food.
He...
That is not correct.
Robots do not consume batteries in the same way people
consume food.
In fact, robots do not possess digestive systems.
Some robots do not even have mouths.
Ooh, get told, Nico.
Now I am looking at the camera, like...
Admito, you made me look silly.
I offended this guy.
I'm sorry.
Hi.
What are you doing up there?
I am stationed here.
By yourself?
Yes.
He hates me.
I can't do anything else with him.
Protect Nico at all costs.
I made him look silly.
I'm sorry.
Oh, there's so much text.
Hey, Sweetie, six more weeks until you can come home.
About time, huh?
Gosh, I can't imagine living in that awful capsule wall dorm
thing.
But guess what?
Soon, you'll get to sleep in a real bed and eat real food
again.
Right back soon.
Oh, mom.
Love mom.
Mom, you're embarrassing me.
Aww.
These exist...
There exist fuel cells that can be powered by glucose and
blood.
If you wanted to, we could make robots powered by blood.
That is kind of cool.
Isn't that concerning for humans though?
What if they make a robot powered by...
Soul?
Like meat.
Like a ghost.
Looks like we're supposed to pack stuff for the evacuation
starting today.
I want to say his books weren't so heavy.
It's gonna be a pain to carry them onto the ship.
But they're by the author.
I can't just throw...
They're by the author.
Oh, the author is like a person.
I can't just throw them away.
Anybody?
Nothing.
I'm scared of ladders.
Nico... Nico does not want to the thrill of going up the
ladder.
Nico says, no thank you.
Oh my god, there's so many buildings.
I feel like I'm gonna get lost.
Evacuation?
As such short notice?
I can't believe this!
First the sun dies, now I'm out of a job!
Not to complain.
Some sort of mechanical drawing.
Robot beyond repair Can I see?
Nothing
What do you have to say for yourself?
Oh, this is the same guy as before So what's his name?
Oh no Infirmary Wait, oh Organic person who is alive The
infirmary is up ahead I was going to say so be here but no.
Did I read this one already?
Oh yeah this is mom.
Let's check out the infirmary then.
Oh my gosh infirmary bot.
It's a box of medical tools.
Most of them are broken or rusted beyond use but this
plastic syringe seems to be okay.
Nice.
Hello person of organic makeup.
Welcome to the infirmary.
Scanning for injuries.
My brain is broken, Doc.
Give me the diagnosis.
Scan complete.
Injuries detected?
None.
Treatment required?
You are good to go.
All right, thanks.
Hello, person.
Are you seeking admission into the infirmary?
Nope.
Oh, carry on, then.
Interesting.
Okay, anything here?
None.
Bill $700.
I looked at you in the eye Give me the money now
Did I go in here?
I think so Yeah That guy who's complaining I'm out of a job
Okay to be fair That's a valid complaint I'm not trying to
minimize His struggles or anything I'm Forgetting what...
Oh, we were supposed to do, like, this...
Empty syringe.
We were supposed to do, like, uh...
Whatever that...
There was, like, something that we read about.
But I don't think I have everything for it.
Can I...
I was gonna say, can I use the syringe to suck up some of
these shrimp?
I guess not.
The importance of cleaning solvents.
Yes, yes, yes.
I wanted to get some of the gas, but these are all too high.
Oh, we're back here.
Wait, so this is a robot.
Wait, we're...
Him, him, him.
This is a robot.
I am functional!
Was that you who fixed the generator?
Well, Admito helped me.
Bye-bye.
Hello, nice to meet you.
I am robot number three to...
You guys!
No way!
Three?
Me?
And then ten?
Tall!
It's Robot Meantol!
Oh my god!
No way!
Robot Meantol!
Would you like me to take you somewhere?
Oh, uh-oh.
Are you okay?
I cannot move.
Well, you're still really rusty.
That is true.
Hold on, Armito and I will find a way to help you.
Let's do the sponge.
The sponge alone isn't gonna remove all this rust.
Okay, we need the cleaning solvent, I think.
He can't move!
Shrimp swamp!
What's that?
Oh, here.
This is a swamp?
Of shrimp?
Shrimp swamp.
The shrimp swamp.
Swamp.
I'm old and rusty.
Trying to think.
Entrance.
What is entrance?
Oh.
Like where we first started?
Huh.
But that's so interesting because...
Oh, he's awake now.
I am functional.
The outfit kind of reminds me of a character in Xenoblade.
The character, the character she looks like, she's like a
robot, but she also looks like Maranette from Miraculous
Ladybug.
Use a syringe on a pool.
I thought I tried that, but it doesn't like interact with it
at all.
Here, hold on.
We'll travel to it.
Maybe I just did it wrong.
Because it won't let me interact with it.
Let's see.
Empty syringe.
Yeah, it doesn't let you do anything.
I did try.
Maybe the bottle instead?
No.
Poppy?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's an area on the shrimp's swamp you missed.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Maybe up here.
Around here.
Oh.
I think I'm out of the shrimp swamp.
Wait a second.
No.
This is the dormitories.
Okay.
Finding this bit took me ages.
Oh, the rare phosphorus.
That's right.
So it's got to be something kind of special.
special now?
Okay.
That's right.
You are right.
You are correct.
You are so correct.
They all look the same.
They all be glistening and glimmer and shine and sparkling.
Did I go over here?
Aha!
This pond sure looks different.
The water looks like jelly.
It's formed a bubble the surface of the pond.
Okay, here we go.
So we're filling up the syringe at Minto?
I guess it's kind of like a funnel.
But the liquid might be a bit too thick to fit in the
needle.
Oh, it actually went in!
Gross.
Let's go?
Okay.
What are you doing here?
The sky is dark.
That it is.
Do you know when the sun will lighten?
be back up.
We're working on it.
Little guy.
Okay.
So we have a filled syringe.
I still need to get the... I almost said ass again.
No way.
I still need to get the... the gas.
But I think other than that, we have everything that we
would need.
rubber gloves in the syringe.
Oh.
Is it the old factory?
Or which one is it?
Yes.
Okay.
I feel like it's gotta be here maybe.
Okay, hold on.
Let me read the...
Okay.
Simple recipe.
Acidic gas.
Blue phosphor.
Rare form.
We got that.
area direct the gas into your container of choice seal
immediately okay
check the liquid phosphor into the container shake shake
vigorously use as soon as possible if elements begin to
separate further shaking as well okay hand protection okay
combine them for the solution yeah yeah yeah i just don't
know i guess maybe it's similar where it's just one maybe
there's one that's like kind of shorter that I missed?
Oh.
Oh, stop it, please.
Hmm.
Like you're drying in front of the mirror.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Oh, yeah?
I can't reach the top.
Is there, like, one by a hill or something?
I'm not tall enough.
If only Nico wasn't deathly afraid of the ladders.
I'm trying to think.
If I go inside the factory...
It's...
Wait, what's this?
Just a hole?
Just a hole.
Wait, is there anything back here?
Anything here?
No.
Hmm, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, this is the dormitories.
I dunno!
I don't know!
Am I, like, just, this...
I feel... I've not seen it yet!
How am I...
Do I have the wrong...
Wrong, wrong conclusion.
Believe the gas vent you're looking for is also in the
shrimp swamp.
Srupp!
I'll check.
Oh, gas vent.
Oh, poinsers.
That's the rare one.
Any teeny tiny gas...
I mean, I feel like I could...
just scoop up the air, you know?
Just a little bit of a...
And that would be okay.
Because there's so much gas everywhere.
Not yet.
Can I get on top of this?
Can't reach the top.
What's over here?
Ah!
There it is.
I guess you want me to fill the bottle with this gas,
Edminto?
Yay!
That ought to do it.
I keep missing these tiny little pathways.
Initially, the amount of noxious fumes emitted by the
natural gas vents caught our team off guard.
Thank goodness the medical team reacted as quickly as they
did.
Despite its failure, that first expedition did bring up some
interesting observations about the barons.
We found that there's not one, but two such vent zones.
With fumes being pumped out at such high concentrations,
that the gas hasn't spread it.
It seems a miracle that the gas hasn't spread anywhere else.
You're not alone in that.
Thank you.
Our biologist concluded that the phosphorus shrimp in the
crater pools were actively consuming the gas.
The shrimp in the ocean also prevent the gas from wafting
off into the glen.
They're hungry.
If that's the case, then we owe a lot to these little guys.
For real!
Okay.
Now we can combine.
Uh...
Where was our...
Rowboat.
Rowbot.
Row-Bobot.
Row-Robobot.
Okay, okay, okay.
You.
Oops.
My bulb is too big.
Shout out to my shrimps.
Okay.
So now...
Bottle of smoke Filled syringe Try and inject the liquid
through the cork, right?
Yes.
It's like I'm a doctor.
Oh!
I should probably shake this too.
Yes, yes, shake it.
It changed color.
We have a bottle of acid.
I'm guessing you want me to pour this acid onto the sponge,
yes.
Good thing I have these gloves.
A good license plate number without the gas.
Oh, thank you!
I got it.
The license plate.
Come on, thank you so much for that 20!
I'm through!
Thank you!
Alright.
Now we have the sponge.
The wet sponge.
Okay, perfect.
Come here.
Alright, hold still.
I have no other choice.
Does this count as a sponge bath?
I think so.
How's that?
I can't move again.
Thank you.
I am able to fulfill my purpose again.
Where would you like to go?
Can you take me to the tower?
Calculating.
Closest destination to the tower is the Glen.
Port number.
My built-in navigation circuits have fried.
I'm gonna assume that's not good.
She's really good.
It is not good at all.
Once again, I cannot follow my programming.
Aww.
Is there anything I can do to help?
In the event of an error, you should speak with the head
engineer.
She will know what to do.
Is the head engineer...
Out, no, lookout point?
Is this our head engineer?
Excuse me again, Miss.
I found a robot who could take me towards the tower.
I was having some trouble, so it told me to talk to you.
All right.
What is the issue?
It said something about his navigation circuits being fried.
Imagine being so good they name you the engineer.
I know.
It's just the engineer.
Just navigation circuits?
Apparently.
Add Minto and I fix everything else, I think.
Hmm.
I have something that may help.
Robots have the ability to trace material from their source
locations.
If you let the robot borrow this, then its backup tracking
system should activate.
Oh!
Oh, CG!
Wait.
That journal we got had a clover on it.
on it too.
You yammeric.
It's like big bars, but for engineer.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a very pretty necklace.
What's it made of?
Amber found from the Glen.
Yay, Nico!
Yay, Rito!
Yay, Emmets!
What's the thing inside the amber?
The black clover?
That's a common plant in our world.
It's also...
Hmm?
I'm not sure if I can bear it apart with this.
My programming says yes, but I still feel conflicted.
Yay, I blew!
This necklace is merch, by the way.
No way.
Never mind.
You need to finish your mission more than I need a keepsake.
Here.
Oh, thank you!
Before I go, is there anything I can do in return?
Could I get a moe moe kume for one year?
Of course!
Moe moe!
Actually, do you know how to play chess?
Yeah!
Well, sort of.
I've played it with some older kids before.
Then will you play a game with me?
I mean, I don't know the rules very well.
But I guess it's the least I can do.
do oh gosh please don't don't tell me what to do don't tell
me i have to play thank you holographic pop doors for about
10 months thank you you're really good at this thank you it
was built into my code ah so what's it like being a robot
and all i've talked to other robots and all they they all
say something about programming and code and stuff?
Even you did just now.
It's a little hard to understand sometimes.
Kicking my stupid feet taking me down.
Of course!
How did I stretch?
I know.
Most of the robots here are not tamed.
Tamed?
Watch out.
Oh, there goes my bishop.
Taming is complicated.
Big stretch.
Hello, Minto, you silly.
Hello, Daisuke.
You're sillier.
How complicated, exactly.
There goes another bishop.
I can't really explain what tamed robots are.
But I'm one of them.
All the other tamed robots have been moved to other regions.
Exactly where?
I don't know.
Oh no.
There goes my little horse.
Knight.
What's the horse?
Horse.
Haunts.
Have you ever been to any other regions?
I heard that there's two more.
In the past, yes.
I still have the data, the coordinates, the memories.
I don't know how much of that still holds true.
The world may be a very different place now.
Umah?
Because the sun is gone?
No.
I said this already, didn't I?
The sun probably won't save the world.
The decaying started before- back before the sun went out.
The sun's sudden death was just the tipping point.
And things went south really fast after that.
Oh.
And there's nothing I can do?
Check.
Ah!
When did your queen get there?
The only thing you can do is complete your pilgrimage.
In a way, you are only supposed to be a second chance for
the people.
Just like how the barons was only supposed to be a second
chance for me.
There's no guarantee that things will work out.
But...
Check me.
Alright.
Guess I've kept you long enough.
Ah, sorry.
Thank you for listening.
I hope you get home safely.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, thank you also.
The music.
So emoy.
Wait a second, what does this one say then?
Oh, the power cell.
Silver is written.
Ah, so this is silver.
Why does it say that?
That's not important.
Okay, so this is silver.
Ah, okay.
We understand now.
Oh, there is a silver.
There is a thing for docks.
I just saw it.
There we go.
Minto robot!
A come bearing gift.
What do I...
What did she give me?
Oh, the amber.
Silver the hedgehog.
Have you talked to me?
Oh, the amber.
Have you talked to the head engineer yet?
She lives near the mine entrance.
I would have given you the coordinates, but...
Oh, that's right.
I have to equip it.
There we go.
Um...
Ad minto...
Is it alright if you let me take a nap somewhere before we
go?
I'm so tired.
I can't even see straight anymore.
Oh.
Okay.
Uh, where was I bed at?
That's not gonna close my game, is it?
Yeah?
I'm a little tired from walking.
Is it alright if I take a nap?
Yes.
That's my game?
Just close my game immediately.
Wait a second.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm still trying to figure out how I can drag this over.
Maybe I should just plug a mouse in.
Hold on.
Wait, I could do this too.
Close.
Don't save.
Give me a second.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Ho-to-binto.
Oh, it doesn't show anything.
Okay, we're fine.
Play.
Play game.
Launching game.
Oh.
What is this?
What's happening?
Oh.
Admito, are you still there?
Yes.
Ah!
Cute!
I had a dream just now.
I saw...
You did?
Wow.
I...
I really thought I was back home.
Well, the sun back in my home world isn't a light bulb.
It's a big ball of fire in the sky.
I don't think I would be able to hold it like I do with the
sun from your world.
Huh?
This isn't the world I live in.
Really?
I guess not.
If you're the god of this world, you wouldn't necessarily be
in it.
What's your homeworld called?
That's a secret.
I see.
Does your world have a sun?
Yes, it's also a ball of fire.
Really?
Wow.
Can you hold it?
That was a silly question, wasn't it?
The sun in my world is very bright.
Warm too.
You saw it, right?
But it goes away sometimes at night.
I think it's dark, kind of like how this world is now.
But it's okay because the sun always comes back the next
day.
That's good, don't you think?
My world is like that too!
Do you sleep during the night?
What did I do?
We go to sleep usually.
But sometimes people stay up and use computers.
Literally talking about me?
I don't have to explain what they are, do I?
There's a bunch of them in this world.
Anyway, we should get going.
Poor Minto robot is like...
So confused.
Called out.
Who's using computers at night?
Who's doing that?
This is Amber from the Glen.
I can remember now.
Activating tracking system.
Setting course.
Wait.
This boat is over capacity.
Wait!
You'll need to leave behind some of your possessions.
Whoa.
I don't think I'll be needing this crow.
No!
My crowbar!
I've never used a computer before.
It's my first day on Earth.
I've never used one before.
Or this gas mask and gloves.
I'm just dumping them into the ocean.
Sorry, shrimp.
That is acceptable.
I was wondering if you have any plans to put your music on
Spotify.
Yes!
Eventually.
I would just talk to Steiner about that today, actually.
So...
Onwards we go.
My crowbar!
Oh, cute!
So cute.
Aww.
The art in this game is so stinking cute.
Fireflies.
Here is your stop, the Glen.
Thank you.
There should be a village to the north, but that's all I can
recall.
Oh, that's good to know.
Farewell.
May your mission be a success.
Are you leaving?
Yes.
I must return to my state.
Is this not the station?
But you'll be home.
alone again it's okay I have not been tamed what's in here
is this someone's house I'm coming in knock knock oh whoa oh
the tower right there we're in the swamp Wow what are all
those bubbles in the water Dickey.
Oh, wait, what's here?
Aha!
Oh, I see.
Nobody's here.
All the trees even have been caught.
That's a person.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
They're playing Toho.
Wait, please.
Please.
Can I just one word to you?
One word.
Please.
Okay, hold on.
He'll come to me.
No, dang it.
I just missed him.
I'm catching fireflies for mommy.
I see.
The jar is full of fireflies.
So we got shrimp and we got fireflies.
Oh my gosh, this is ASMR for real.
The sound.
Oh yeah.
Sounds good.
Wait, hold on.
You would not believe your eyes.
Hmm, nothing's batting.
I see.
What about you?
I'll bite.
There was a time where our people used to live in these
ruins.
What are you doing now?
But due to flooding, most of us have moved to less permanent
settlements.
Can mean to be a fish?
I'm a piranha.
There's one missable thing in this area.
Do you want us to tell you if you miss it?
Oh, yes, that would be good, I think.
Flooding.
Aye, the land has gotten brittle.
The Glen used to be in One Piece.
Did you guys see the season one of One Piece's ending?
I had no idea that One Piece was literally one season long.
I cannot believe that.
what just watch one piece bro it's only one season long it
gets good in the second season just stick it out bro it's so
dumb i love it so stupid it's so funny the one season just
it's one season bro Come on!
But now it's just a bunch of islands that get smaller and
smaller.
Oh my gosh, Florida.
Are these...
So these are fireflies.
Oh, excuse me.
Fireflies, yeah.
It's a bed.
Well, more like a mattress.
A futon.
Warm coals.
Soup?
Fish stew!
Yummy.
Filled with small dried fish.
I'm so Florida-brained.
right now.
I go to Florida once and I make it my entire personality.
Oh wait, this is where I came from, though.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Did I drive Wawa as no?
Oh!
What is this?
Can I go in here?
Last week I saw more of those squares while out fishing.
I knew better than to get too close, though.
Squares?
Squares, man.
They're bad news.
Love this game.
Very comfy.
Thank you!
Oh, Nemesis!
Thanks for three bonds.
Thank you!
The squares.
Stay away from the squares.
Sheep.
Whoa.
I didn't expect...
I didn't expect a sheep sound.
Oh.
What do you do?
The crops have been growing poorly without the sun.
And there's no telling how long our surpluses will last.
Please, Savior, you have to hurry.
I'll do my best.
Hi, Minto.
Hi, Vic.
Bye, boys.
Thank you for 19 months.
Bye.
Hmm.
I need someone to help me herd my rams.
Oh, I could do that.
do it at back home you kind of just push him around hmm but
you are carrying the Sun ah wait can you just watch the Sun
for me that seems I cannot I am but a simple Shepherd I'm
okay come back when your hands are free he will be rewarded
if he can herd my Rams okay is this guy all right what's
wrong with him
Oh my gosh, Oregon Trail.
Heya.
You here to trade?
Trade?
Yeah.
Is there anything you want to get rid of?
Make me an offer and I'll give you something in return.
The sheep on something else must be a skinwalker.
Do we have something like that, Adminto?
Just give away my son.
I offer my son.
What was this?
Some kind of cloak or shawl folded neatly.
It's a pair of shoes and some jewelry.
Looks like an altar.
Did we put the sun here?
The staff?
Reminds me of the one that robot from the barons is holding.
It's an orb!
The material looks like amber.
Oh, I wonder then.
I guess not.
Minto complete the ritual.
The goats are after me!
I can never escape the goats!
Are they buy in?
The flood can take away our farmlands.
But it can't take away our fish!
So true.
Complete the ritual.
Oh, what's this?
The doorway is full of vines, Adminto.
I'm helping set up a new TV I hope I don't drop I hope we
don't drop We can never escape the goats Because you are the
god Next
You flatter me What's going on here
Wee Wait Is this guy still screaming?
Why is he like that?
He's like trying out for some sort of band.
Oh, you guys on fish stew?
Looks like moss.
Oh, never mind.
I guess people eat those.
Coles.
It's slowly being chipped away already, but it's still
trying to stay alive, I think.
Doesn't matter.
One day the world will finally give up this fight.
I just hope I'm not alive to see.
it i'm bringing back the sun though that won't fix the root
of the problem just like the other lady said but don't lose
heart without the sun the world will die much faster at the
very least i'm sure everyone would love like to see the sun
again guys doesn't seem so good seems a little bleak the
land is fragmenting at an alarming rate when this town
finally loses to the intruding sea.
We'll have to find another place to settle.
Or you could evolve to have to have legs.
I mean, no, sorry.
To have fins
and gills.
Just be like those creatures that were like, I don't want to
live in the sea anymore.
And then they hop on land.
Okay, granite.
Is that the sun?
Yeah.
And you're holding it?
Isn't it hot?
Not really.
It's nice and warm.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Don't send Lincoln here.
This is it.
The last of our grain surpluses.
And now we're dealing with a vermin problem.
Maybe you can get cats?
Not that I'm a cat, I mean.
Oats.
Heads of hoit.
Looks like flower.
Oots.
What's this one?
Fireflies light up the room.
That was a bright room.
Wow, there's so many houses.
It's not ready yet, but would you like some stew?
I'm not hungry, but thank you.
It's the least I can offer the same.
Savior.
Oots.
You're going to get dizzy if he keeps spinning around like
that.
I'm the tower.
Oh.
Grandpa says the tower used to spin all the time bringing
sunlight to the world.
I want to see it too.
Well, I'm here now.
I guess it'll only be a matter of time again.
Spin, spin, spin, spin.
Most of the green moss covering our village has already lost
its glow.
If it wasn't for the thin strip left on the boundaries of
the land, people could easily fall into the ocean.
Without light, land and water becomes indistinguishable
here.
That's true, though.
It's kind of scary.
Oh my gosh, the ocean at night is like scary.
It's so dark and vast and everything.
The sun is a lighthouse.
It seems like it, right?
So this is where we came from before.
Yes, there should be like that little girl running around.
There she is.
Okay, cool.
Where have I not gone to?
Uh, I went in here before, right?
Yeah.
Um, okay, so now we can go down.
I don't think I, yeah.
Was there anything over here?
Let me just double check.
Mm-hmm.
Cool.
But when there's a full moon on the ocean, it looks so cool.
That's true.
Alula?
Alula, where did you go?
Alito, did you hear that?
Alula?
Is that berry bug?
I think it's coming from southeast of here.
Well, these trees are kind of freaky.
Hey, you there.
Have you seen a little girl?
She's a little bit shorter than you in.
Wait, that's the sun.
are you our savior are you oh my stars sorry for my rudeness
it's all right are you looking for someone my little sister
she's been gone for three days I've been looking all over
but what does she look like a little shorter than you long
blue hair two blue feathers on the top of her head I'm sorry
I haven't seen anyone like that freaky a freaky freaky is me
freaky where was the last place you saw her back inside the
ruins she said she was headed towards the forest so i'm
waiting here now i ran out of places to look i guess we look
for her then she fell into this square oh my gosh what if it
like the land fragmented while she was just standing there
sucked her in whoa this place is a maze oh whoa
How tall is Minto?
Like, actually?
Or in the game?
Not a dream like that once.
I've been reading this webtoon.
Um, called, what is it?
Fourth period?
It's like something period clash.
But I can't remember what number it is.
Oh, 44th period.
survival class it's like yeah 44th period classroom yeah
i've been reading that and it's basically about like uh
about like these holes that are just opening around on like
just anywhere they're just kind of like and people are like
what are these holes and when you go in like you don't only
few people have gone in and come out and basically this
whole school gets like sucked into a giant hole
they are in there and like it's their school but like
there's monsters that have kind of like been created based
off of like the the rules of the school so for example
there'll be like a um like no wandering the halls during
class time kind of monster so they have to wait until like
the breaks in between classes to go explore the area.
It's pretty interesting.
Sounds like Corpse Party.
Sort of.
It's interesting.
So far, I'm kind of into it recently.
It's neat.
I'm into it.
Yeah.
What was the name?
44th period classroom or something?
Yeah.
it's kind of it's just a little spooky like the monsters are
like a little unnerving usually but it's not like I wouldn't
say it's horror horror but just a little a little spooky
44th period survival class yeah that one that one yeah
that's my my recommendation currently hello person welcome
to the research station hello are you sent here by Dr. Suss
Silver Point.
No?
Oh, carry on then.
Oh, okay, fine.
You hate me.
Who are you?
Research Station.
Hello.
Did Dr. Silver Point send you?
No, I'm with Admin, though.
Oh, carry on, then.
Oh.
I want to learn.
I want to...
Oh, the bots are discussing.
How come you're red instead of green?
Well, more of purple than red.
But your eyes and stuff are red.
I am only here to pick up this week's moss samples.
I will return to my station in the city soon.
I see.
I let VTubers influence my game purchases.
What do you mean too much?
I think it's not bad.
To, you know, you see somebody playing a game and then you
want to try it out yourself?
I think that's totally reasonable.
Hold on, you guys.
I'm going to be right back.
I'm gonna go get some more juice and by juice I mean tea on
your back I will be right back right right back right back
right back
I'm back I'm back I'm back I'm back Wait a second My
headphones are Oh Yeah Ta-da-da-da
Let me set up everything.
Okay.
I'm gonna have some of this throat syrup because my
throat...
I'm still recovering from holiday Matsuri and all the
speaking I had to do.
So when I talk for a really long time, my throat's been
hurting a bit.
Okay.
What's this guy saying?
I am in charge of collecting the moss samples.
Cool.
What's in here?
Oh, who are you?
Hello, person.
This is the main generator of the Glen.
Whoa.
Yeah, that throat coat.
Adminto and I actually fixed one of these earlier in that
place across the ocean.
This generator does not need to be fixed right now.
Right, you guys already have power and all.
Yeah, but what if?
The generator.
This one's got a working battery.
Okay, cool.
The other place...
This place is actually kept taken care of and not neglected.
Are you also going to deny me?
Phosphor trees.
Oh, this is phosphor.
Yeah, this game does have a lot of dialogue.
That's okay, though.
Okay.
Phosphor trees are now being protected under new laws.
Takizawa!
Oh, thank you so much for the thank you, dude.
Thank you.
I'm stuck in a blizzard in Hungary.
A blizzard?
So you can't order food.
I think you do have to resort to cannibalism.
Might be the only way.
I would say goldfish.
Cheez-its?
Cheez-its and goldfish?
You know, okay, there's just one thing that might be...
friend taught me a while ago this one meal it sounds it's
it's basically a meal for children but sometimes i crave it
you get the pilsbury crescent rolls not croissant the
crescent rolls and you take them and there you lay them out
you you peel them apart and they're like little triangles
okay and then you put like maybe uh like maybe like four
pepperoni little like individual and then you take a
mozzarella stick mozzarella cheese stick and you snap it in
half and you put it on the pepperoni and then you roll it
and then you kind of fold the sides in as well no yeah yeah
it's like a pizza roll basically and then you get the pizza
sauce and you you cook it and then you get the pizza sauce
and then you dip it in there and you make yourself like a
little little individual pizza It's pretty good.
It's better than like a pizza, like the frozen pizza roll
things that you can get.
It's really good.
It's my, it's my little, you know.
It sounds like a meal for children, but it's really yummy.
Thanks for the foodie app.
You're amazing.
I'm going to do it.
Yeah!
They're really, they're really tasty.
And it's pretty, you know, you can make a good amount of
them because the crescent rolls.
They come, I think, like, with 12 or something like that,
so...
And then you just need the mozzarella's cheese stick, and
then you just need the pepperoni, and it's really...
It's not so expensive either, I think.
Meal for adult children, perfect for me!
Yeah!
Anyway.
Please do not harvest the trees.
I'm not?
Okay.
I will not harvest the trees.
Phosphorytree growth rate has been reduced as of late.
Oh no.
That doesn't sound very good.
This whole game seems a little...
See, we're in the squares!
Monitoring anomaly.
What is that thing?
An anomaly.
Well, yeah, but...
Hmm.
Beep poop water collection project resuming.
He said the thing!
He said the beep poop!
Hello living person.
Hello.
I have collected a duplicate water sample.
Would you like it?
Yeah, sure.
My programming says that organic beings need water to
survive, so I shall offer it to you.
Oh, sure, I'll take it.
I like how Nico says we, because it's also me here too.
Stick a dark chocolate in there instead, and that's my
gourmet chocolate-filled croissants, which have won me
lifelong friendships and $80 one time.
Inside the crescent roll?
No, why?
There's a little glass of...
It's full of little glass tubes of water.
Oh, water samples!
Tube of water.
Those crescent rolls were my childhood.
Sometimes we'd...
Ah, fireman!
We'd take the dough and wrap it around a hot dog to make
piggies in a blanket.
That sounds good!
That sounds good.
I think I already went up here.
I want to make some now!
I don't think this... I don't think store will still be
open.
Unfortunately, once I'm done with stream, maybe I'll make
some tomorrow.
Piggy's in a blanket.
Wait, I thought we were not supposed to harvest the trees.
Why are there trees that have been harvested then, huh?
Ah, that looks illegal activities.
So we're also looking for a little girl.
Oh, close that down there.
Water sample collection in progress.
My family will put all kinds of things in crescent rolls
like chocolate chips, nuts, cheese, sauce.
Dang!
Okay.
Would you ever make them on stream?
I don't think it'd be so exciting, though.
but I mean, if you wanted me to.
Oh!
The sun.
You are the Messiah.
Are you on your way to the tower?
Mm-hmm.
You can enter the refuge through this wall.
You'll need to sign your name on this scroll first.
All right.
Do you have a pen?
Um.
No.
I've lost mine.
Perhaps you should look around the Glen for another.
Okay.
Interesting.
Ooh.
Hello, person.
Please do note that the ruins below are partially flooded.
Oh, should we not be here?
There is no immediate danger.
Using this area as a dwelling is not recommended, however.
We just want to hang out with you, Minto.
No.
I want to hang out with you guys, too.
Oh, blinds.
Vine boom.
A cluster of vines are blocking the way.
The sound is so... it's giving Barbie movie.
With how crisp it is.
Oh, computer!
Hello again, Adminto.
It seems I need to help you again.
Why does it sound so ominous though?
I got sick.
Today is such a Christmas.
You heal me.
Go Flarex, feel better!
Feel better, feel better, feel better!
Minto Energy!
What prompted me to play OneShot?
Just curious?
I don't know, I just, I was curious about it too.
I just remembered the game, basically.
Nico will not be able to progress otherwise.
This time the information you need has fallen to you.
to the most easily accessible place on your machine.
Do you see it?
Uh...
Oh, oh, oh, no.
I know you're not exactly that bright for a god, Edminto,
but this shouldn't be difficult.
Just poke around a bit, and it really isn't hard to miss.
My desktop?
You call me stupid?
Is it like...
Hold on.
ViviCorps, thank you so much for the capture!
Thank you!
Hold on.
Oh, I'm stupid.
I'm pressing the wrong thing.
Documents.
I'm gonna go to downloads.
Pictures?
What is the most...
What is the most accessible place on my PC?
Huh?
I have literally nothing in here.
Like...
Pictures?
Nothing.
Check the back of the game case.
Oh, wait.
I just noticed...
Wait.
Did it turn purple?
What is this?
Did it change my wallpaper?
Oh my god!
What?
Oh my god.
It's Orpal.
That's crazy.
Free wallpaper.
Wait.
What was this supposed to be?
Oh.
You remember the document, correct?
This time it's even more obvious.
What's the most easily accessible place on your machine?
Yeah, but what is it?
You will know when.
Okay, okay.
That's so funny.
I'm like, what?
What does it do for, like, um...
I know this game is also on, like, console, right?
I think Switch?
What does it do?
do in for some of these then these vines appeared mere
minutes ago really i've been seeing a lot of them in
doorways and stuff oh it uses a virtual machine oh a fake
desktop oh i see i see oh that's what the the version the
like virtual machine version that okay i i see i see i just
assumed it was because this place was abandoned a sign of
distress huh a living being is in need of help, but I cannot
trace the source.
The little girl probably.
Okay, we're running.
Wait, where did I come from?
I think I came from up there.
Hello, person.
Two children reside near here.
Two?
Two of them?
The pathway is blocked.
Aminto wrapped 2025.
Wait, what does that mean?
You can unlock wallpapers for the fake desktop in-game.
Oh, that's fine!
By blocks!
It's blocked by blocks.
I thought we weren't supposed to live here.
The music in this game is so good.
Savior.
I can't believe it.
You're real.
Miss?
are you all right no we should get you to the village maybe
they could it's okay it's okay too late for me what the sun
i haven't seen it i haven't felt it in so long savior if
it's not too much trouble can you lend me the sun for a
while but will it make you better no it will not save me
experience the sun one more time before I, well, oh, would
it, would it be too selfish of me to ask?
What should I do, Admin, to give her the sun?
Here!
I have almost forgotten.
It's so warm.
That's good, right?
God, no.
I'm not afraid anymore.
Oh, it's dark.
I didn't realize how dark it was when we don't have the sun.
But now our hands are free.
There was, like, that one guy that was, like, come back to
herd my sheep when your hands are free.
And the vines are gone.
Oh.
The vines receded.
Do you know what happened?
I found this plant person.
She was barely holding on.
I gave her the sun for now, but she said it was too late for
her.
I understand.
I need to report this to the city.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
We got a snitch.
Where am I?
Oh, how handy.
Oh, no.
Your hands are now free.
Would you like to help me herd my rams?
It's a great reward in store for you, I promise.
To the south is a peninsula inhabited by my rams.
They are all standing in unfortunate spots.
You need to move them onto the darker moss.
If you get stuck, ring a bell and they'll all return to
their original positions.
Good luck.
Wait, so down here?
This?
It's a puzzle.
Oh,
I think I get it though.
no!
I just realized I trapped...
Wait.
Why can't I just pick up these dang?
Oh my god.
It's like a strength boulder puzzle in Pokemon.
It really is!
I just realized I messed up.
Oh no!
I don't want them all to return.
Oh.
There's no saving.
Ding-a-ling!
Now I have it.
Well, you've provided a great service for all of Ramkind.
In return, take this fine Ram war.
Oh, thanks.
This guy?
What about him?
You're heading to the city, aren't you?
Been there.
Done that.
Too cramped, you know.
It's cramping my style.
But it's not like this place is getting any bigger with the
rising waters and all.
Maybe the city isn't so bad after all.
So do we take this?
Wool.
It's kind of useless.
Do we trade this then for something else?
Want to trade?
Yeah.
Is there anything you want to get rid of?
Make an offer.
Okay.
I think I have something I'd like to trade.
You'll take wool, right?
What can this wool get me?
Wool, huh?
That'll get you this fine vial of.
I'm not sure what this is at.
A vial of mysterious liquid?
Some sort of fabric dye.
I'll take it.
I'll do it.
Pleasure doing business!
Bottle of dye.
For dyeing wool.
But I don't have the wool anymore.
Wait a second.
What if I use it on that guy that's spinning around?
Dang, I thought I was gonna...
I
can't remember anything that I need to do except find that
little girl.
And also, whatever my wallpaper is now.
You must perform the ritual.
They're so well-behaved.
It's on their individual spot.
I just gave that to you.
Oh.
You want to trade it back?
really good because i wasn't gonna okay i can't remember if
i've wandered if i've like oh wait uh if i've what places i
haven't been to you know the wallpaper won't happen right
away funky oh can we go get my light back maybe we take the
sun back no oh
wait is this still blocked Yes.
Blocked by blocks?
The sound of the shoes is way too, like...
Way too crispy.
It sounds so good.
It's impossible to find a place you haven't been to.
I guess that's fair.
It's the sun.
We're leaving it with her for now.
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
I don't come get it.
Oh, my bad.
Thank you!
Are you guys ready for the good ASMR?
I'll even turn it up.
Listen to this.
Wait a second, oh, because...
What areas?
Uh...
Oh, this is the computer.
Okay.
I wonder if I ask again.
Are you gonna get mad at me?
By the way, the effect is temporary.
It will be gone once you no longer need it.
Okay, thank you.
It's like, um, excuse me?
Um, I'm scared.
Did I come out?
Did I...
Oh, what's this?
Okay, it must be this then.
Ah, I see, I see.
Uh, where's my mouse?
Oh.
Okay, that should be easy enough.
One, two, three, one, two, three, one, two, three.
Okay.
Come back.
One, two, three.
Oh, wait.
This might be it.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, we found her!
He saved me!
Thank you.
I was trapped in there for so long.
So are you Alula?
You knew my name?
Wow, the Messiah really does know everything.
Actually, I just met your brother earlier.
Alright.
Gosh, Calamus must be so worried.
Can he bring me to him?
Okay.
Oh yeah, my wallpaper really did change back.
Crazy.
Alright, come on.
She's not following me.
Uh-oh.
Where are you going?
I'm leaving.
Wait a minute.
How did you know that I was the Messiah?
I don't have the sun with me.
Your eyes.
They reminded me of the sun.
So cute.
She's so cute.
Oh, that's why you're our Messiah, right?
Well, I...
A lot of people back in my home world have eyes like mine.
Home world.
Yeah.
I'm actually from another world, you see.
It's a place where the sun is in the sky and not in a tower.
Do you like this world, too?
Uh, yeah.
Yay!
Callimus says, keep saying how this world is getting more
dangerous by the minute.
That's okay.
You're here now.
You can make everything better.
Yeah.
She's so cute.
I like how she was like, where are you going?
Why don't you follow me?
Yeah.
Okay, so I think we go up here.
I think we go through here?
Yes.
And now we are back in the forest.
Okay, yes.
So now we go find the big brother.
Big bro, big bro, big bro, big bro.
What's this?
A bed!
Uh-oh.
It's gonna make me sleep again.
It's gonna be like, you know what?
I'm sleeping.
Before we go to the city.
Oh!
Calimus!
Alula!
You're okay!
The bed?
Okay.
Thank goodness.
She was in that room for three days, isn't that what he
said?
I was trapped inside this room and it was really scary, but
then the Messiah saved me.
Trapped?
In the ruins?
Yeah.
There was that weird stuff on the door.
You know, the floating squares we see next to the ocean
sometimes.
The stuff you told me to stay away from.
what it's spread to the ruins now this isn't good don't
worry i didn't touch it her face is so cute i like her face
i'm not hurt or anything still if it gets any worse we might
have to find somewhere else to live what is this square
stuff exactly bad there's an allula plush on the store i did
see when I was looking at the game on Steam that they were
like, get the stuff in the store.
Like, it's a...
This game is old, no?
This game is pretty old.
Anything that touches them just sort of gets messed up.
Whenever you hear people say that the world is decaying,
that's what they meant.
Obviously, you should avoid them too.
I will.
Yeah, almost 10 years.
2016.
We're close to...
We're just a couple days away from 2026.
Is there anything you guys want to do in the last couple of
days of 2025?
Honestly, though, as a ghost.
The years don't really feel very, very different.
You know, like, when it changes to a new year, it doesn't
really feel so different.
Watch me, though.
I think I I kind of want to do It's not like exactly a
countdown But I will be streaming On 31st And then And then
I actually have two streams On the 31st But one of them is I
think PST time So So Yeah, 2.
Feels wrong saying 2016 will be a decade ago.
I know!
Because 2016...
It's kind of insane, right?
I'm like, if I think 2016, I'm like, oh my gosh, that feels
recent.
But it's not.
Oh, Doki announced it already?
Oh, okay.
Doki didn't leak anything.
It's her event.
But yeah, there will be a sloppy sister's countdown on...
the 31st.
So, yeah!
Yeah, we'll be hanging out together.
But I will not be streaming my side, so I apologize in
advance.
Alrighty, 1.20 a.m.
time for me to go to bed.
Good night!
Scratch!
Thank you.
Good night.
I hope I adore it.
But I won't be streaming it because it's like, Uh...
I've been having issues with VR, so I'm like...
I don't think I should stream.
I apologize in advance.
Oh, that's what he says too.
Anyway.
I can't thank you enough for rescuing my sister, Savior.
Just call me Nico.
Oh gosh.
Would it not be rude to call you by name?
Huh?
Why would it be?
I mean, I'm just a kid like you guys.
Then, would you like to visit our house?
Yes.
Yay!
Let's go.
I'm going to their home.
Oh!
This is where they live!
In the ruins.
Oh, shoot.
Looks like we can't get past that block.
It's just a block.
How was your Christmas?
It was good!
How was yours, Jacob?
Seriously?
I'll be up ahead.
I literally never thought of that.
You kind of get used to all the debris after living here for
a while.
Come on, our house isn't far from here.
Um, Nico.
Nico stupid.
Welcome to our home.
I know it's not much, but feel free to make yourself
comfortable.
Ah, there it is!
Here, we want you to have this.
What is it?
It's...
Oh!
Cute!
Oh, it's a feather.
The edges are glowing yellow.
It's a sacred feather from the great prophet.
Oh?
Yeah.
She's this old lady our dad used to know.
Her feathers can glow in the dark.
She can see into the future.
Now I can double jump.
Yippee!
What?
Or something like that.
She gave one of her feathers to father before she died.
Door draws a move.
Wherever tell.
Welcome to a bamboo ship!
Thank you!
Father wanted to pass this down as a an heirloom although it
feels more fitting for you to have it are you sure totally
sure i think that's what our father would have wanted thank
you glowing feather fireflies you would not believe your
eyes you would not believe your eyes it's good to be home
again oh by the way what happened to the sun i lent it to
someone in the ruins she said she wanted to feel the sun
again before she Oh, you must be talking about maize.
Is that her name?
She's a powerful plant spirit.
She used to protect the Glen.
But once the sun died, her health rapidly deteriorated.
Oh.
Corn.
I'm glad you were able to find her in time.
I think we might already be too late to save her.
I know.
But I'm glad she got to see the sun again.
There's so much back here.
Wait, there's three beds.
There's one for their papa.
The back room is full of dust and cobwebs.
Aw, there's three, though.
Zantos, welcome to Membushup.
Thank you!
Oh!
I saw you going to the courtyard.
So I thought I'd tag along.
Same.
This area is so cute.
Ball.
It's a ball.
That's my.
It doesn't bounce as much as it used to, though.
What are these?
Fish.
Fish!
How can we protect without our tiny souls?
Stop.
Don't say that.
Don't
mention...
Just continues.
Oh, magic trick.
It looks like this used to lead somewhere.
Heaven's division
Yeah, the sacred grounds It's been a while since we went
there We don't have a way of getting there now, remember Can
they not swim?
There isn't a boat And none of us can swim Well, the game
totally answered my question What's the sacred grounds?
It's where our people are buried Sometimes we go there to
visit mom.
Well, her grave anyway.
No.
Wait, how do you get there?
I thought you said there isn't a boat.
Oh, our friend helps us.
There's some sort of machine that allows him to fly.
Sometimes he takes us along.
But like I was about to say, we haven't seen him around me
for a while.
I wonder when he'll come back.
I wish we could go see mom again.
This is so sad.
Let's go back to the courtyard now.
The audio is delayed.
Like from the game?
Is it okay?
Audio is okay?
Might just be me.
Uh oh.
Funky.
Funky, funky, funky night!
Poop is a poo poo.
Funky, funky, funky night.
Are you leaving now?
It was nice to meet you.
Really, thanks for everything.
Aww.
Are you leaving now?
Good luck, Nico.
We believe in you.
This game is so sweet.
It's so sad, but everybody's so nice.
Alright, let's go get our son back.
Our son should be down here.
my son
we also now have this feather with glowing edges oh I wonder
if we can use the dye and the feather like an ink to sign
our name
wait the light's gone out and Minto?
did you know what happened?
no
Oh, what am I gonna do?
Oh, it's back on.
It lit up again.
Phew.
She's gone.
Oh, there's something on the ground here.
It looks like a kernel.
A kernel of corn.
She must have left it, but she really was.
She was corn.
Colonel.
She must have left it behind.
A seed.
It's a seed apparently left behind by maize.
Wait, can we go plant it?
Let's see.
There was that area where the crops were.
Let's go see if we can plant it.
How do I get out of here?
Wait, I think I remember.
Right here.
Oh, wait.
Wait, where- oh no, the vines were- sorry, I was not- I was
thinking of- I thought this was the area with the vines.
I'm stupid.
Mays is corn in Spanish.
Yeah, exactly!
She is corn!
She is- she was corn!
I thought it was just a silly name that they gave her, but
it's real.
I wonder if I can trade her corn.
I've been growing poorly without the sun.
There's no telling how long our surplus.
You have to hurry.
I'll do my best.
Can I plant it?
Doesn't look like I can.
What if you fed the corn to the sheep?
And then, when it poops it out, it's fertilized.
And that is the circle of life.
It's like what happens when birds eat seeds.
Yes.
We will fertilize her.
Oh, I gotta go back inside here.
We gotta go to the robot.
Was it this way?
I think so.
Yes.
We're going to the big city.
I'm going to the big city on my own.
Oh, wait.
Let's do feather and then the bottle die.
We can use the feather as a pen.
Oh, nice.
I saw it in a picture book once.
I don't know if that's the, we're using this like, this,
this magical old lady's feathers who has already passed
away.
We're using her, their family heirloom as a pen.
I guess it works.
Adminto, I'm too tired to go on right now.
Please let me not for a bit somewhere.
I remember seeing a room to the west.
It looked like it might be a good place to take a rest.
Okay.
My game's gonna close.
I'm a little tired from walking.
Sorry if I take a nap.
Yes.
Goodbye, game.
It's so funny.
Okay.
You can see some of my games.
Play.
We're dreaming again.
And...
So cute.
I mean, though, I had another dream.
Did you see this one too?
Yeah.
I was in a big field, like the one in my last dream.
Spicey wolf.
And I saw my village!
But then I woke up.
I don't think this world has anything...
I don't think this world has anything like that.
I mean, big wheat fields.
The only big plants I've seen here are a bunch of weird
trees.
And those balls of moss floating in the water.
Wait, is moss even a plant?
Say, have you seen a wheat field before, Adminto?
Yeah, actually, have I seen a wheat field before?
I don't know.
Have I?
I don't know if I ever have.
If you've been to the Midwest, then yes.
I don't think so.
Is it a myth?
I don't know if I've ever seen one.
I'm going to say no.
Oh, well, they're really pretty.
They look like...
Wait, you just saw one in my dream.
The one around my village goes around for miles.
The plants are really tall.
Sometimes I can't even see through them.
I don't think I've ever seen a wee fill before.
Okay, looking out a plane window is...
It's totally different.
The wheat is a myth.
The plants are really tall.
Sometimes I can't even see through them.
When it's windy out, the wind can make waves in it.
I want to see!
That's my 2026 goal is to see a wheat field.
I want to see it.
I don't know if I've seen one either and it's blowing my
brain.
I know because you think of a wheat field.
You know what it looks like.
But now I'm like, I've only seen them in movies.
I've only seen them on TV.
I've seen them in games, anime.
I've never seen in real life.
I've never seen!
That's my goal, 2026, is to see a wheat field.
Now you're making me question if I've seen one or not.
I don't think I've ever seen one!
I'm gonna go see one.
It's like an ocean.
A food!
Oh wait, but there's food in regular oceans too.
Like fish or crabs.
I've never actually been to a real ocean until now,
actually.
I've been to the ocean.
Yeah, I have.
That's really cool, Adminto.
I've only seen the ocean on TV.
This is, see, this is literally me, but with a wheat field.
Time to drive cross country.
Yeah!
I never thought I'd get to ride a boat through one.
The water back home doesn't have glowy stuff like how it is
here either.
Ah, but I guess it's because the world is already so dark.
You know, I used to be scared of the dark, Admin, though.
It's a little hard to imagine that now after spending so
much time here.
Not long ago, I couldn't even go to sleep without a lamp.
That's me now.
I can't go to sleep without a lamp.
Me too!
Really?
Even though you're a god?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I can feel my head expanding.
It's a good thing I got over that fear.
Otherwise, I wouldn't last long here.
Then again, I've been carrying around the sun, so it's not
too bad.
And also, I don't feel scared at all with you guiding me.
So thanks for that.
Anyway, maybe I should head out now, Adminto.
Um, I was told that there is something that I could miss
here.
Did I miss it?
I sleep with the TV on.
I need...
I sleep with YouTube, yeah.
Protect this cat, Minto.
How are you?
If nobody knows, we'll just continue onwards then.
Let's see.
Because I think we'll probably have to get rid of, like, the
tube.
Have you seen corn?
I love corn.
You could have haggled the guy earlier, I think, for extra
wool.
Oh, no!
Oh, oops.
Oh, well.
Okay, well, we'll just go onwards then.
Have you found something to write with?
Yes.
Oh.
I found a pen!
Sort of.
Good.
Please write your name here.
I did the sound effect for me.
Don't worry, you got it.
There's another thing that could have been gotten if you did
the sheet puzzle.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Corn is pretty great.
I like it with a little butter, salt, and pepper.
Yes!
I love.
Good luck.
Thank you!
World!
Uh-oh.
The anomaly!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running.
I'm scared.
It's kind of loud.
Does that scare me?
The big city!
Wow!
The sounds are crazy.
The sun.
Hello, Messiah.
Welcome to the refuge.
Do you understand what you must do here?
I'm supposed to go inside the tower, right?
I already see the tower, so I guess we must be close.
Where's the entrance?
On the surface.
The surface?
Look down, small one.
Whoa, we're pretty high up.
I guess I gotta get down a lot of stairs.
We're finding an elevator.
However, the tower is a sacred place.
Finding the entrance may be easy, but that alone will not be
enough.
What do you mean?
Once you reach the surface, I recommend visiting the library
for leads.
Alright, thank you.
You mean I gotta read?
Nico's afraid of ladders, but not heights.
I think I get it, though.
Ladders are kind of unsteady.
And then if you slip, that's it.
Off you go, then.
I wish you luck.
Oh, I'm afraid this area is off-limits for you.
Only the bearer of the sacred kernel.
Oh!
As permitted access...
I have a kernel.
I have the sacred kernel!
Oh, like a kernel of corn?
I have this.
It was left behind by the plant lady in the glen.
That is indeed the kernel!
It is your duty to regrow her.
Do you understand what you must do?
No.
Take the seed to the garden.
Plant it in the pot in the center.
You may now pass through here to access the garden.
Oh my god, we are planting her!
Here.
It's the similar symbol as before.
The one that was my wallpaper.
How is she going to grow in here?
With this corn, we make the last...
Oh my gosh, we're going to make a cornfield.
Time to put the seed in the planter.
There is no dirt in this pot.
Will the seed really grow like this?
Suddenly, like, feel a rumbling.
And it's my tummy thinking about eating corn.
I'm kidding.
It's her growing.
And work already!
Huh?
What was that?
Oh.
Why isn't this working?
I think someone might need help.
Anomaly.
Do you have water?
Oh wait, I did have the test tube of water.
Let's go back up.
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
Wait, do not use the water yet.
You need another item to upgrade the water for...
Wait, would it let me use it?
That'd be kind of messed up.
Hello.
Come on, come on.
I'm too busy for this.
Excuse me.
Right on time.
It does let you!
Oh wait.
that.
Oh my gosh, it soft locks you!
Oh,
you're you.
Oh, geez, I didn't think I was going to run into.
This is embarrassing.
Is there anything I can help you with?
Yes, please.
I would like to know how to get to the surface.
Yeah, I was afraid you were going to say that.
Right now, the elevator is the only way to access the
surface, but...
Yeah, just take a look at it.
It looks like an elevator?
You need to use the normal water first, then refill and
upgrade the new...
Wait, wait.
Wait, you can refill it.
There's an unlimited sink later.
Oh, well, if I don't need it right now anyway, like if it
doesn't work, then I should just wait until...
Until I need it, right?
I think?
Needs dirt first, too.
Yeah, I think we'll just...
Yeah, we'll just wait.
We don't need to go.
Well, you're not wrong, but go look at the button panel.
There aren't any buttons.
Yep, that's the problem.
There's usually a big button here that says ground on it.
You know, because it takes you to the ground area.
But now it's been ripped out or something.
I tried looking everywhere for it.
To no avail.
Maybe it exploded.
Do you think we have to make a new one?
What?
How?
it out.
Okay, cool.
Fix it, Nico.
What's here?
Bed.
Okay.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
I was jamming to that.
Locked.
Locked from the inside.
Lacked.
What is this?
Oh, robot house.
A landscape painting.
Abstract painting.
She's abstracting?
Are you an intruder?
Because if you are, I model 8-XM home security bot TM serial
number 39232 232b839w4 will have to report you.
Oh, sorry.
I kind of just walked in because the door was unlocked.
I have a friend.
She does that where she tests me.
She's like, Minto, are you locking your doors?
So if she comes over, she automatically just tries to walk
inside.
Was that an amazing digital circus reference?
Maybe.
So like, when my And when she comes over, if I know she's
like on her way, I'll just hear her like, like, I'll hear
the doorknob move and then like a, because it's her like,
like trying to like, like running into the, into the, what's
it called?
The door.
Everyone has that one from that breaks in.
So true.
Do you want me to leave?
Scanning for suspicious activity.
Suspicious activity is detected.
Breaking in is not a suspicious activity, everybody.
You heard it here first.
One-shot has outlawed breaking into a home.
You can do that.
It's not suspicious.
I guess as long as I don't do anything bad.
Huge.
Adminto.
Someone lives here.
We can't just sleep in their bed.
It's off.
Out.
Outlawed, you're right.
What is this?
Dirt?
A small potted plant.
Take the dirt.
A sink.
Oh, wait.
Skizzers.
A pair of scissors on a pile of hair.
I don't think anyone's using it anymore, so...
I need scissors 6-1.
Do I use the scissors on here?
No.
Skeezors.
I can break and enter into here.
They're my type.
Wall of family photos.
I will unequip the scissors so we do seem less scary.
Guys, there's a girl in the new Pokemon game that I feel
like I want to play the Pokemon game.
because of her.
Her favorite clothing store is called Wisp.
It's called Wisp.
And Anonymous Agony needs to join that desktop.
And she plays with Gengar and and and and she's dressed like
a chandelure.
She's everything I could ever ask for.
Do I rip this guy open?
Is a big penguin?
Hello penguin.
Hello, penguin?
Hello.
Pink flower.
It's pink.
Why did he speak?
But I don't remember the girl in Pokemon.
I don't remember her name.
So you guys could be saying things and I don't know if it's
her or not.
Oh my gosh, it's Neptune.
It's Nep-Nep.
Would you like to play a game?
Sure.
What game would you like to play?
Do you know Rock, Paper, Scissor?
Desire difficulty level.
She also likes cute girls.
Yeah, I know.
She loves the Giaru streamer girl.
I was like, is she just me?
Uh, desired duration of turns.
Uh, please set your timer.
Never mind.
My parents are like, literally never home.
But I don't mind.
I'm used to it.
Besides, I've got Model C, W2, 2nd Gen Unit 4E here to keep
me company now.
She still talks a little weird sometimes, but that's okay.
She's learning.
If I work real hard, she might even be Tame someday.
I keep hearing that word.
What?
Tame?
Mm-hmm.
Nobody's told me what it means yet.
That's just like a robot thing.
I can't really explain it either.
I'm going to look up the camera.
character you guys keep saying.
What was it?
Uh, Ian?
Okay, mine.
Win.
Yeah!
She's so cute.
I was like, I think she's me.
I think she might be me.
She's so cute.
Love her.
Love, love, love her.
And I would love, love, love if, you know, I don't know.
If anybody ever wanted to make fan art of me and her outfit.
That would make me so happy.
Okay, more breaking and entering.
The bells.
What is this?
Something has been chewing on this plant.
I just moved here from the Glen.
Things are so different in the city.
right yeah everything's so green back there i really miss it
my neighbor gave me some plants to cheer me up but i should
probably get a bezel for betsy there oh my god betsy the
title is city life what to expect
bye bye bye uh here there's so many places what is this a
room I'm not sure what this is.
It's like a little car.
You should ride it.
What?
Do it!
Um...
Oh my god, he's so cute.
Can
I take it?
It's off.
We're leaving with it?
Well, that was fun.
Ah!
We ride at dawn.
Fun?
We have to get... We have to get soil here.
A small garden trowel.
The handle part is shaped like an owl?
I get it!
Noom.
I like to stand in the middle of the wheat field back in my
village.
Oh, it goes on for miles.
I wish I could have seen it.
In our world, wheat is usually only grown in small...
I didn't realize, sorry, I stopped reading it out loud.
Wheat is only grown in small isolated plots or in a flower
pot.
Wait, who are you?
Hello there.
You have a lot of plants.
Never give an owl a trowel.
A trowel.
I do.
I grew all these myself, you see.
Feel free to ask me about them.
Oh, you're a gardener, right?
Yep.
Do you happen to have any dirt?
For growing plants, I mean?
Yep.
Do you need some?
Yes.
I'm supposed to plant this seed left behind by a plant lady.
The pot in the garden doesn't have any soil.
I see.
I know who you're talking about, yeah.
Here, take this whole bag.
Thanks.
Yippee!
Okay.
We got a big old thing of dirt.
Is this the sink?
That I couldn't...
Wow, there's so many...
A phosphor tree.
Yeah, like the ones we saw in the glen.
I always wondered, where are the leaves?
They're not dead, are they?
I was thinking, we have a whole bag of dirt.
strong.
Not at all.
Although these trees are composed of a woody tissue, they're
closer to grass, anatomy-wise.
So the branches are actually leaves?
Sorta.
What's interesting about these plants is the amount of
phosphor sap they can generate.
Phosphor, that's the glowy stuff, right?
Yep.
Phosphor can store light energy and slowly emit it over
time.
Most of the phosphor from this world still contains energy
from before the sun went out.
Without the sun to recharge them all, well, let's talk about
something else.
so sad okay well we got our dirt let me see is there
anything else down here no there were quite a few areas
though like this where whoa what is this coffee machine warm
is this the library they look like phone books we got TV
head man we got plant pot man Head...
Head... uh...
Whoa, shiny!
The fridge has magnets on it.
Maybe they'll come in handy?
I hope nobody will mind me taking them.
Oh!
Okay.
A fridge.
Just a trash can.
He sat too close to the TV.
That's what your parents always warn you about.
Don't sit too close.
Hmm, we'll come back.
We can go do the dirt and...
Maybe the water, even though I have to upgrade the water or
something.
Oh, this is the bathroom, that's right.
And where we got...
The scissors.
I think we've been in everything around here now.
This was locked, right?
Yes.
Okay.
So this leads outside.
Yes, yes, yes.
And this is the elevator.
Yes, yes.
Wait, did I go down here?
Oh, the bed.
Yes, yes, yes.
And this is abstract.
Those squares again.
Okay.
Well, I'm just exploring now, but it's kind of crazy.
Wait, is this another...
Okay.
I thought this was going to be like another apartment area.
What's this?
Empty toffee.
Toffee, toffee, coffee, coffee tin.
Hello.
How come there aren't any people here?
Normally, cafes have tons of people.
Yeah, it's a really slow day.
You think it's because the ground access elevator is broken?
So I've been told.
The city's infrastructure has been suffering a lot lately.
Lady.
I can't speak anymore!
Well, I almost said sidewalks instead of skywalks though.
Mint skywalker.
Skywalks and stairs breaking off left and right.
Now the only reliable way of transport are those elevators.
anyway.
I'm gonna take a sippy.
And I'm gonna have a mint.
Nice.
Okay.
We're good guys, we're good.
We're all okay.
There's only, there's not many places we can go around here
though.
Don't forget to stretch!
Yes.
Oh, we got a clock, girl.
Good evening.
Well, the time of day doesn't really mean anything now.
With the sun gone, the night never seems to end.
Then how can you tell?
Time I mean.
I have my ways.
She's a literal clock.
Evil.
You're going to need this soon.
take this film and expose it to the void the answer will be
revealed when you bring it back again a computer printed out
a strange print transparent sheet bring it to the void a
transparent sheet filled with numbers what do the numbers
mean the void huh
heavy piece of metal set into the wall I think it might be a
door of some kind There's a small screen here in the middle.
Okay.
I'm exploring this mysterious area.
Infamous puzzle.
What does that mean?
If you hold a clock girl's hands, it's like time has
stopped.
What's happening?
I've actually never been to a big city before.
All these lights, all these people.
I guess most of this world's population lives here.
Oh!
Time has stopped.
This puzzle is absolutely next level, very good stuff.
Hmm.
It's very different from my village.
The village is very small and surrounded by huge fields.
You saw a bit of that in one of my dreams from a while ago.
The tallest buildings in our village are only two stories to
How far am I running?
What about you, Enminto?
Where do you?
Um...
This isn't gonna, like, say anything bad, is it?
Well, Nico, I so happen to live at...
Virtual Hackyama!
The game does not docks where you live.
A city.
A city like this?
Wow.
I can't imagine living in a city.
What's your IP address?
Admin, though.
Must be exciting.
Kind of scary.
The view is nice, though.
Oh, did I just go in a circle?
I think so.
Just a little place where we get to learn more about nico
cute we've got her gang she lives in a city oh no and don't
go to maid cafes that would be the worst don't go to maid
cafes looking for me don't go to maid cafes and and support
the maid cafes of akihabara and you know moi moikun and
everything while searching for me in akihabara
Let's get going!
I'm headed to the city right now!
A tape dispenser.
It's bolted to the table.
If I cut off a piece of tape, it would just lose its
stickiness.
Oh, I guess that's fair.
I don't even know what I need the tape for.
They are just bolted so people won't seal them.
Feel free to use, though.
Why was it in such ominous red...
Some kind of computer terminal.
I am the power room mechanic.
Do you have an issue to report?
Yeah, actually.
The surface access elevator appears to be broken.
Oh, maybe we use the tape for the button.
Can you go take a look?
Leaving this room is not in my programming.
Ah, never mind.
Hmm.
Maybe, do I use the magnets?
That's what I was thinking.
I forgot that was our ultimate goal.
The magnets don't stick to aluminum.
Hold on now.
I'm gonna go back to the computer for a hint on this puzzle.
Hint!
Still clueless?
Figures.
One another tip, yes.
There's a void beyond the four walls that bind our world to
yours.
The edges of your viewport, where everything is obscured.
So the window?
I'm sure you know what I'm talking about.
Pass the film through the void and back again.
Uh...
Wait,
oh...
Uh...
Wait...
I'm trying to figure out how to do this.
I might have to plug in a mouse.
Yeah, because I can't drag the window.
So give me one second.
I'm gonna go get another mouse.
Okie dokie.
Let me plug it in.
Let me turn it on.
Okie dokie.
And okay, cool.
So if I...
Whoa!
63014.
What?
Well, at least I have a mouse now.
Proper mouse.
was there a thing that needed the digits though or oh
there's notes even oh that's this thank you thank you
that was crazy that was cool oh my gosh I'm so glad I'm
playing this game not desktop right or not game capture
Write that down!
63014.
Let's put the dirt down.
Oh, you're a little corn kernel.
You want to get all dirty?
Yeah.
Ew.
Where is it?
Oh, dirt.
I hope this helps you grow, little seed.
The seed's in the soil, but it looks a bit dry.
I'm gonna try, see what happens.
Good thinking, Adminto.
the seed grow.
The dirt's nice and moist now, but what if it dries out?
There's only so much water from this little tube.
I'll hold on to the tube for now, just in case.
She's dry.
She says, please, Admito, I'm so thirsty.
I'm so thirsty.
I'm just a little plant, and I'm so thirsty.
If it's been ripped out, how come there's an There aren't
any broken wires inside the empty slot.
Playing mist helped.
Cool puzzle, though.
Honey, thank you for the simp or die!
Well, I'm no engineer, but...
It's powered by some kind of magnetic technology.
A man said something about magnets, but I don't see any way
to fit these into the panel by themselves.
Me immediately grabbing them.
I think you'll be able to make that button?
Well, no pressure, kid.
I'll just stick with my original plan for now.
Time to kick the door again.
Kick!
My foot hurts.
I can't remember where I need to go.
Okay, this is bed.
Probably before we go down the elevator, we gotta go to bed.
I keep going to the bed.
Just call me.
What was her name?
Call me.
Rio, yeah.
Thanks for the years to be with us.
Damn!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
The bed?
Right.
In her mouth.
Gustav's room.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
All right.
I'm going to go through all of these places again.
See if I missed anything.
Maybe she'll talk to me now.
Okay.
Oh, we don't even talk to it anymore.
Oh, my God.
Wait, do I have anything that I...
I could like...
It's so scary.
It's so freaky.
It's way too freaky.
Hello.
Oh.
Where?
Ride the Roomba.
The Zumba.
Oh wait, there was this area.
I forgot to talk to this guy.
That's so true.
Hello.
Hey there.
You the Messiah?
Mm-hmm.
I like your scarf.
Thank you.
Mama made it for me.
Tell her I like her needlework.
I will.
When I see her again.
That's all it was.
Looks like I can unlatch this door.
Just a trash can.
Did I go through here?
Ah!
Wow, it's a shortcut!
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, okay, okay.
Nice.
Okay, that's handy, I suppose.
Thank you for the stream.
Adminto.
X-ray!
Thank you for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you!
Oh, wow.
Most of the plants in our world tend to grow in the glen.
Even if it's facing the flooding issues, it's still a better
condition than the other two areas.
as well, the barons.
And Refuge City is barely enough ground to stand on, let
alone grow stuff.
On a larger scale than this, I mean.
Good luck with that scene now.
Can I fill it here?
I can refill this tube with more water here.
Okay.
Is there a way to make it better?
Oh, no, nope, nope.
Tube of water.
Hmm.
Filled with plant clippings.
Black clover.
Probably the only plant hardly...
Hardy enough to survive naturally outside the gland.
Firstly, I think they're really boring to look at.
One of my customers really loves them, though.
I think of all the black clovers I'm growing here.
Wait, wait.
I think all of the black clovers I'm growing here are for
him, actually.
Come to think of it.
I haven't seen him in a while.
I wonder when he's coming to pick these up.
Do you think it's...
elevator okay cool thank you i wonder what was his name kim
guys i don't know is it okay let's see what we can combine
maybe you can make a button cut out a piece of the can and
fold it into rectangle ship shape make arts of crafts whoa i
don't think it's supposed to be this simple how are we going
to connect it to the elevator maybe okay what we can do is
then tape it to the button it says ground because it was
ground coffee and then um wait where was the tape oh and
then we magnet it we have to tape the magnet to the back
because magnet does not stick to aluminum i think it was
over this way
yes Down here?
Or no, no, no.
Okay, we got this guys, we got this.
Yes, okay, so now we button.
What if we just folded the magnets under this edge?
Oh, wait.
It's holding together, but just barely.
I hope that's good enough.
Magnetize button.
Wait, okay, then if we do this and maybe tape it together.
A tape dispenser.
I gotta tape it together, it might fall apart.
There we go.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
I cooked!
Go!
Let's hope this works!
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh.
Reactivating elevator services.
Please input security code to continue.
What?
That's never happened before?
The squares?
Huh?
You saw them, right?
We're on the door and...
Nah, the square stuff happens all the time.
I meant the whole security code thing.
Then again, the elevator hasn't been this broken before.
I know the code!
80085!
Guess we should go look for a code ad, Minto!
I know it!
Oh, what was it?
Wait, hold on.
63014.
Should I be worried my cat is swatting at you?
Six?
Three?
Oh, one, four.
Yippee!
What?
It works!
I don't know what you did, but it actually works!
Good job, kid.
You're a genius.
My head is getting bigger.
Fat, fat head.
You're a genius, you know that?
Well, I had help from Admito too.
Alright.
A whole messiah business.
Anyway, ready to go?
I'll be up ahead.
Yon, I'm having trouble staying awake, Admito.
We should find a place for me to take a nap.
Sleep time.
Wrinkly brain.
Yes, yes.
What are these?
I thought they were gravestones.
Just like home.
for me i'm a little tired from walking it's all right if i
take a nap yes okay shut the game all right let me uh open
up the game once again
pancakes oh my gosh looks delicious
We're gonna get you home so you can eat pancakes from your
mama!
Admin, though, I had another dream.
Mama was there.
Did you see her?
Yes.
She made me pancakes!
I think it was my birthday.
Because people always get their favorite food on their
birthday.
A whole lot of it.
You have a birthday too?
Wow.
Yes?
Oh!
And what's your favorite food?
The pancakes?
Wait, do you like pancakes?
Okay.
Confession.
I don't really like pancakes, but I don't want to make Nico
sad.
What do- do I lie?
It's just a small lie.
I like waffles.
So you're going to lie?
I mean!
I don't know, I don't want to make him sad!
Okay, I'll be honest.
Be honest, he'll be fine.
I'm honest, I'm an honest mid.
Ghost mid.
You can like both.
No, I just actually don't like pancakes very much.
They're like too doughy for me.
I don't know what it is.
I just like waffles.
I'm honest.
Maybe you should give them a chance, you know.
Fine, Nico, for you.
I'll give waffles.
I mean, wait, I'll give pancakes a chance.
Yeah, I have waffles on the brain.
My mama makes the best pancakes.
And some of the neighbors really make really good noodles.
Wait, you're actually the meme.
No, I'm not.
I'm not the meme.
Oh, wait.
Because you like waffles, you like...
don't like pancakes?
Oh yeah, I'm the meme.
American pancakes are also too thick for me.
Try other styles.
I've tried like the fluffy ones that like kind of jiggle
wiggle, but they are also too... I just don't like those
either.
I think because they're made with egg.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Stop painting on me!
Try the flatter ones.
Maybe... Wait, but those are not pancakes anymore, right?
That's like a flapjack.
Right?
That's a flapjack.
I think the crispier ones?
What about banana pancakes, though?
That's my exception to pancake hate.
I think I'd like anything with a banana in it.
That's a crepe.
Maybe.
I do like crepes.
I like those.
Yeah.
You agree with me?
Thank you.
Anyway.
Neighbors make really good noodles.
Oh, and one of our neighbors makes a lot of bread.
Do you have any neighbors?
Mm, yes.
Do they share their food with you?
No.
That's not very nice of them.
Our neighbors and my mama take turns making food for the
whole village each day.
Do you...
Raise your hand if you know your neighbors.
Do you know your neighbors?
I could be your neighbor If there's an abandoned maid cafe
Right next to you I could be your neighbor And you wouldn't
even know You'd be like Oh there's that abandoned maid cafe
And It could be me It could be And you would never know
Because you don't share your food with me
My neighbors are pretty far away
Far away neighbors That's kind of nice too, no?
I know their dog
Everyone also takes turns doing chores And watching the
little kids I don't need to be watched anymore though I'm
old enough to help out I miss everyone I've been gone for a
while now haven't I I wonder if they're worried about me
with lots of syrup.
I like butter on my waffles.
Yo, minto.
Darn, darn, darn, darn.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Speaking of helping out, we should probably go now.
We'll get you back home, little buddy.
All right.
Down the elevator, we go.
Oh, hey.
Welcome back.
That sure took you a while, huh?
Oh, shoot.
You've been there.
been waiting the whole time and holding the door open?
I didn't want to be rude.
I'm sorry.
I should have told you to go on ahead.
Don't worry about it.
Here we go.
Sure it's taking a while.
Don't mind the maid cafe next door the ghost there has food
aggression.
Skately, welcome back.
French toast is a Superior Breakfast Bread IMO.
It's okay.
It has to be made, right?
Oh goodness gracious, I'm stuck in an elevator with the
Messiah and I literally god themselves.
This is awkward.
Well, maybe we can chat to pass the time then?
You heard me?
I mean, sure.
Alright.
Admito, should I...
Resume the awkward silence.
Guys, I have to use a little ghosty's room, I'm so sorry.
I've taken many a break of the stream, I feel.
Me running all over the place.
But I have to use the ghosty room.
So, um, awkward silence.
There we go.
I'm back!
Sorry!
Guys, I think I need to change my headphones.
Because my ears are like...
I need to change some of the other headphones.
Sorry about that.
I was like petting my cats too.
I was petting my cats.
Nice.
Yeah.
All right.
Awkward silence.
Nice.
I was just about to ask how the cats...
Yeah.
I went out earlier when I went to go get water before and...
They were...
They were snuggling with each other, which they don't do
like ever.
So I was like, oh my gosh.
Memboos are permanent.
Permanent?
We made it to the bot.
I should have probably asked about stuff, huh?
Superliminal!
You made it!
You got the hot dog!
Anyway, it was a nice meeting you.
Nico!
Right.
See you around, kid.
Gotta run, though.
It seems in a hurry.
I guess we should hurry, too, Admin, though.
Eternal Membu?
What if I turn Membu ships off?
People are counting on us!
Let's go find that library.
I'm not feeling like I want to stop anytime soon, but does
anyone know if I'm, like, what, halfway through the game or
something?
How far I am?
You would.
She hates money.
Guys, everyone's welcome back.
Thank you.
This is the last area.
Hello, person.
The library is up ahead.
Thanks.
Oh my god, crazy hair.
When the world ends, would it be better if it was gone in an
instant or slowly failing away?
To be honest, I'd rather the former.
More than half.
Just a little bit more?
Okay, cool.
This is library?
Cool.
There's so many people here.
What?
Oh, I didn't say anything.
Stop staring at me then.
I was just looking at your book.
Yes, you are in a library.
There's books in the library.
Go bug the chatty one upstairs.
My goodness.
The author's book cover...
Books cover...
cover a wide range of top...
Oh, the author!
It seems there are no subjects he does not write about.
Quite the Renaissance man, don't you think?
I guess so.
But he's been focusing on documenting the world as of late.
Oh?
I say the city is the last bastion of civilization.
Soon these books may be the only thing we have to remember
the rest of the world by.
Oh.
Books are neatly placed on the shelf.
What is he wrote?
write about.
Look how cute!
Still scared of ladders.
What the heck?
Hello person.
Hi.
Reshelving in progress.
Please watch out for potential... Oh, I guess maybe if they
drop boxes out with this one.
Some sort of plaque.
A computer is currently off.
Denied.
A photo of some people.
Hello, do you need directions?
Let's see, this area here is mostly historical accounts.
The reference section is downstairs, and I'm not sure where
the children section is.
That's okay.
I'm not really looking for books.
Oh, are you here to look for the author?
The author?
No?
Oh, that's good.
I mean, that means you won't be disappointed.
I've been volunteering here for months, and I've never seen
him not even once.
He works together with the head librarian on publishing.
He shows up once in a while.
But he doesn't?
Yeah, where's the dojin shape?
Yeah, he's kind of reclusive.
Which is weird for a guy who supposedly travels the world.
Maybe it's just around people.
Oh, sorry, I had to move some stuff on my computer.
Whoa!
Where are these people coming from?
The author is so cool.
I heard he can travel all over the world with a flying
machine.
that's how he gathers material for his books wait didn't the
kids in the Glen say that their friend had a flying machine
well are they friends with the author a photo of some plants
some sort of plaque a big book with a black clover on the
cover the title says a Comprehensive guide to phosphors.
I'll have to read.
As a general rule, if a phosphor loses its glow entirely, it
cannot be relit unless exposed to the sun.
If the phosphor is merely dim, it may be impossible to boost
it through exposure to another phosphor of higher energy.
But even so, the boosted phosphor will never return to its
original brightness.
A survey of phosphors found in the natural world.
Blue phosphor.
Green phosphor.
Red phosphor.
I was just making sure what it said.
Out of the common phosphors, blue phosphors of moderate
levels of energy.
It can exist in both organic and mineral forms.
Skip a skip a.
The mineral form is just because I have my headphones in.
My mouth is hurting.
I'm from talking so much.
Uh.
The mineral form is most commonly found in the metallic
sands of the barrens.
Yeah, yeah.
Live phosphor of shrimp can be used.
Eepy ghost.
Don't say eepy.
You can say eepy.
Green phosphor.
Out of the three common phosphors, green phosphor is the
highest energy.
Also, the rarest of common phosphors is only being found in
organic form.
Include the sap of the phosphor trees, fireflies, and
various mosses.
Oh.
Thankfully, at least locals of the Glen still have enough to
get by.
Ideal for industrial use, however, due to its relative
scarcity and past over-harvesting.
There is currently no reliable source.
This one, we don't know.
The refuge.
Out of the common phosphorus, red phosphorus is the lowest
energy.
How many times do I have to say phosphorus?
It exists exclusively in mineral form and can only give
light to...
when in solution.
The dilute red phosphor abundant in the city's water
channels can be concentrated and induced.
Wait, so how do they drink water?
This can create an artificial high energy state with
great... Wait, so if I drink the water,
I would be so...
It's like a crazy energy drink.
Red Bull!
The water here is red bull!
Probably.
One major caveat is that the phosphor in this in the super
saturated solution will precipitate out rather quickly.
As soon as the phosphor recrystallizes, it loses its glow
permanently.
If using super saturated red phosphors as a power source,
make sure there are proper facilities or services that can
replace every color.
Cuphead!
Hey, who are you calling Cuphead?
So what do you think about the author?
I don't know.
Have you read his stuff yet?
you should okay is this the author of writing these things
the author's latest novel latest books are really something
yeah the head librarian just released a bunch last week oh
they're big compendiums you'll see them if you look around
kind of different from his earlier works though i'm used to
reading reading his travel logs novels mostly nerd kid the
author publishes books on a highly accelerated almost
inhumane pace in fact he has put out more books in one year
than most authors do in a lifetime.
According to the head librarian, there is still a large
amount of material he has written and not yet published.
One cannot help but wonder where he can get so much done in
so little time.
I did the calculations, and the numbers simply do not add
up.
Maybe he can stop time.
No such mechanism exists in this world.
It is actually impossible.
Wait, is that actually possible in your home dimension?
Nah, I just saw it in a movie once.
About superheroes and stuff.
We have this big book with Black Clover.
Emergence of the new ecological niches in a post-sum.
In a post-sum world.
The book bored me.
Don't fall asleep in the title.
We got the phosphor shrimp.
Common firefly.
Oh, that's it.
We can read this.
Also known as seed shrimp in the certain vernaculars due to
the shape of their transparent coats.
These aquatic invertebrates are the most abundant life form
in the oceans surrounding the barrens.
0.5 centimeters.
That's as big as you guys!
A nocturnal beetle with a vibrant glow, sometimes captured
in mass and put in jars to be used as living lamps by the
Glen's residents.
This has inspired the now common practice of using
phosphorous shrimps to do the same.
You're going through these pages pretty fast.
Actually, it's mostly pictures.
Oh?
Yeah, the author doesn't only write books.
He also illustrates them.
Sometimes he makes books out of only pictures.
Neat!
For you?
We are one-fifth of an inch tall.
Yes.
So cute!
That's above average.
We're all so luminescent.
You could be probably, yeah.
Like a little willow wisp that glows.
The eye blue also glow.
Will I ever write a book?
I don't think I can and I'm not good at my words, I think.
You know, I've tried looking for the flying machine with my
binoculars for ages.
Never saw such a thing though.
I like how his eyes are like glinting.
Uh...
What are you doing to that book?
What are they doing?
Don't worry, these are my own books that I wrote.
I just pulled them off the shelves to modify them.
I have to cross out some seconds.
Are you the author?
Most sections.
Eh, I'll come.
Because otherwise they'll think I copied him.
Him?
The author.
I mean, I really don't see the point of writing anything
anymore.
The author is just gonna write about the same thing and then
everyone will love it.
Nobody's gonna remember the books that came out before his.
Oh, I mean, I ain't hating.
I can see why people go nuts over his stuff.
major talent.
I was falling asleep at his title, though.
But it just hurts, you know?
It's never fun when people call you a copycat for something
you wrote about first.
I can see that.
People call me a cat all the time, even though I'm a person
and cats are pets.
And mousers?
Why is your hope people don't think I eat mice?
Then I guess we're in the same boat, kiddo.
Robot, excuse me!
Oh, you are the Messiah.
Welcome.
When I first entered the city, a big robot told me to look
for a library on the surface.
This is the same library, right?
This game came out on Steam around the same time as
Undertale, though the original is older.
I think this guy is...
This guy is a statement on how some probably thought the
devil was copying the Undertale.
Oh no!
You can't make an RPG maker game anymore.
There's not...
How is this a copy of Undertale?
There's no combat or anything in this.
Mice cheese?
Pancakes.
Yeah.
Not the meta one.
Yeah, you can't make a meta game anymore.
Quirky RPG equals Undertale.
No!
And then quirky...
quirky visual novel is Doki Doki Literature Club.
And you think that's a little meta and kind of horror is
Doki Doki Literature Club.
Affirmative.
Oh, goody.
Well, we're here.
What do we do now?
The big robot.
Robot.
Oh, they said there'd be clues here.
That is a question for the head librarian.
George.
Allow me to call her.
George?
Get on the phone.
dialed to George big robot she is not picking up is she not
here she is here she is in the archival room upstairs when
she is concentrating on her work she will ignore any and all
phone calls for several days oh no Yikes.
Can you go get her in person then?
Leaving this post is not in my programming.
Then can I go myself?
Of course.
The archival room is accessible through the stairwell behind
me.
Gotcha, thanks.
Who are you?
Oh, I thought he was smoking like a bubble pipe.
I'm on my third cup.
I can't feel my limbs.
Oh my gosh.
But I have to stay awake.
I need to find out how this book ends.
Curse the author in his beautiful cliffhangers.
A bubble pipe.
Unauthorized entry.
Library card required for further access.
Wait, what?
I don't have a library card, though.
Where can I get one?
This is a question for the head librarian, George.
Allow me...
No, please.
No, I didn't.
Dang it, I was just trying to get to the other side.
Me.
she is not picking up i figured are you sure you can't just
let me through letting you through without a library card is
against my programming oh my god someone tamed this guy oh
i'm gonna tame you i'm gonna tame you little robot even in
an emergency my programming is not flexible
been tamed.
Ugh.
What do you mean I'm making it sound weird?
I'm literally just saying what it is.
Coffee cups.
Coffee is for grown-ups.
I could do some coffee right now.
Okay.
Maybe I talk to him one more time.
I'm guessing you don't give out library cards.
I only handle book transactions.
For people who already possess cards.
Ah.
To acquire a card, you need to contact the head librarian,
George.
No.
No!
Don't call!
Okay.
Alright.
We'll figure...
Wait, is there anything?
No.
Wait, maybe I wonder... The strange journal.
Oh!
There's a book I found back at the Barron's area.
Since this is a place for books, would you happen to know
what it says?
I do not recognize this language, but the symbols on the
cover is of importance.
What?
The head librarian George can explain that.
Would you like me to call her?
Don't.
Okay.
Hmm.
Yeah, if only we had a crowbar.
And then we could bash his head in and go, you know.
Make things a little bit easier.
Alright, everybody.
Time for your Red Bull!
Um, I don't remember.
We were in there for so long.
I don't remember where we came from.
It's locked from the inside.
Is that the tower?
Wait, it might be.
This is where I came from.
Oh, no, it's not.
Hello.
Fish aid.
The big fish tank.
Hey there.
You have a lot of fish?
Yeah, I'm worried about them.
Red bull.
Oh.
I heard something about how square particle stuff just took
out a major pipeline.
I guess I should take advantage of the running water while I
still can.
Oh, no!
The world is disintegrated.
What's this guy doing?
Evening news!
Are you here to purchase a copy?
No?
Newspapers are for grown-ups.
Grown-ups?
Yeah!
What does that mean?
It means people who aren't kids.
Kids?
Aren't you a kid?
I am a robot!
Right.
Extra, extra!
Read all about it!
This is telling me to go up here.
Nico, be careful!
Admito, did you see what happened?
Yeah?
My vision went blank for a second.
And then I saw something?
Like a really short dream.
I wonder what that was about.
Faded flyer.
A curious marking on the wall.
Looks like a ram?
Whoa.
Strangely warm in this room.
Look at all the kitties!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, a cat.
Are you lost?
Me?
wish to join?
Oh my god, what he thinks we're a cat.
Join your cats?
Yes.
But I'm not a cat.
I don't walk on four legs like they do.
You have cat eyes.
My eyes are normal people eyes.
Well, normal back home.
Your hat is shaped like a cat.
But I'm a person.
You are still welcome here.
I protect lost people as well.
Thanks.
But I'm not lost though.
I've got, I mean to the guide me.
Oh, but what if I'm lost?
I see.
I'm lost, I think.
What's up here?
More alleyway.
Ugh.
There's so much bag full of trash.
Oh!
What's happening here?
Please!
Do not approach!
That guy...
He's getting eaten by the... by the blocks!
Wait, this is the fox we just saw.
Whoa!
Adminto, did you see that fox just now?
Just ran up... ran behind that tree.
I'm sorry if you were looking for me.
But I cannot talk to you.
No, he's Minecrafting!
No!
I want to be Minecrafting!
now um but can you promise me something
hmm if you can find a way to return please do what do you
mean by that no reply
this everything is so mysterious The guy's getting eated.
Oh my gosh, this...
I mean, I know we're in, like, a city, but this area is so
big.
Holy cow.
What's this?
Some big plastic discs in here.
Looks like they're supposed to go in something?
Are we really gonna take these with us?
They look so heavy.
You carry dirt around.
They're actually pretty light.
Jar full of red glowing liquid.
Frame photo of someone.
Lantern plant.
There's a note attached.
It says, thank you for working so hard, Mr. Lamp Lighter.
Big book.
The title says, Understanding Robots.
Okay.
I don't think we can't take it, right?
Nope, okay.
Hey kid, want some soup dumpling...
Oh, that sounds good.
They're guaranteed to contain only a minimal amount of
industrial byproducts.
Oh, pass.
Soup dumplings.
I love microplastic!
This smells kind of nice.
What is it?
Breaded fish.
I toasted the bread myself.
I see.
I'd still hear that.
Are you here for your photos?
No?
Alrighty then.
I'll just, uh, stand here.
Wait, is this a door?
Oh, it is.
A slot here.
Looks like paper or something might come out from it.
Didn't do anything.
Wait, these look like...
Looks like something could fit in there.
Oh, you got several kinds of lenses, I just noticed.
Watch me one-shot this.
That's the name of the game.
Oh!
I guess that wasn't the right combination.
Title drop!
I almost did it, though.
This stand smells a bit like burnt sugar.
Yep, still getting the hang of making these fried candy
skewers.
They don't taste too bad, though.
Do you want one?
It's okay, but thank you.
Hey, hi!
Ready for me to blow your mind?
Yes.
You don't need anything else for that puzzle?
It's not going to give me a hint or anything, though.
Okay, so I've invented a medicine to prepare everyone for
the upcoming water shortage.
All you got to do is dissolve one of these pills in water.
And then you drink the water.
Then you never need to drink water again.
This is what I need for the...
For the...
For the kernel!
What?
It also makes plants grow faster.
How does it work?
Here, why don't you take a free sample?
Oh, thanks.
Don't thank me.
Go spread the word!
Way!
Oh my gosh!
Goes in water.
water supposedly.
But like, wouldn't you have to keep taking it?
Pill in the water.
Medicated water.
Okay.
Maybe we go back.
Sparkly.
Spooky?
Spooky.
Wait, where am I?
Oh.
What is this?
Locked.
And ordered again.
Further access to the labs, you must pass the security
system test.
Uh-huh.
You must change the color of the lights into a specific
configuration.
Allow me.
Two lights correct.
Wait.
Oh, A-tr- Wait.
Oh.
Okay.
There must be a hint for this one.
I won't keep going.
going.
Thank you for the stream.
I wish you the best for... By the way, never be afraid to
share your thoughts and opinions because there's no reason
to be scared of.
Take care and golden sleep.
Come even though.
Mobius, thank you.
Good night.
Sleep tight.
Sweet dreams.
The luminescence index of red liquid phosphor decreased by a
factor of 3.57% this past week.
Wait, is it Wirtle?
It's just Wirtle.
Alarming to say the least.
I didn't realize it would reset it, though.
I thought it was, like, one and done.
So, okay, we can try it then.
That's the sharpest decline I've seen, and the number is
only increasing.
We'll have to further concentrate the phosphor now, for it
will be...
For it to be of any use.
It's hard to believe, but there's a good chance the city
could run out of light in as little of six months!
What are we going to do?
That don't sound good.
Oh, okay, we're here.
It may help you to go one color at a time.
Beep, boop.
This is the printer room where machine parts are made.
Also robots.
It can also help to write down previous attempts.
Management.
They're backseating me?
I don't appreciate this.
backseating.
I didn't ask for your help.
If all else fails, wait for the puzzle to reset.
Maybe you'll get an easier one next time.
I don't remember what I tried.
Three lights correct.
I should have done one at a time, huh?
So I believe these two are right.
Never mind.
I want to redo.
Because I don't remember what I changed.
I'm just...
That's fine.
We'll just restart.
Intruder detected!
Resetting lock mechanism!
Okay.
Time to start over.
Alright, here we go.
Zero lights correct.
Okay, so it's...
None of them are orange.
Wait.
Let's see if we can figure out how many are blue.
Two lights are blue.
This might be stupid, but...
None of them are green!
So they're only pink and blue.
Wait, what?
It didn't it say two were wrong?
Wait.
Oh, two were correct!
Oh, I thought it said zero were correct.
Too blue, too.
Should I have done the colorblind mode?
Maybe.
Okay, so this one is definitely blue.
Oh!
Okay, so it's green, blue.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay!
Let's try pink for this one.
So it's still, okay.
Maybe this one's green.
Yippee!
I did it.
I'm a genius, I'm a genius, I'm a genius.
Oh my god!
My robot!
What happened?
Do not approach!
Uh...
Do we help or...
Oh, okay.
Hello, scientists.
Monitoring, monitoring.
Yeah, science!
Ah, those squared particles just took out two of my robots
in the Glen.
We might have to put off the water analysis project for now.
The Baron's engineer have reported another sighting of the
particles in the cliff area.
Well, nothing unusual at this point.
I'm picking up some more disruptions and such a raid of the
city.
This is consistent with our earlier findings.
Not good at all.
Tidhead!
She says, forgetting the statement about no...
Shh!
Cease!
I wonder what the author would do in this situation.
Dr. Silverpoint usually references his works.
None of us have been sleeping very well.
well in light of recent events.
The square particles took out a few of my robots last week,
and...
She fell asleep.
I can barely keep my eyes open, man!
How does Dr. Silverpoint get all that energy?
These robots are malfunctioning at a frightening rate!
Oh my god!
Do you think that sheep was a robot?
Physical damage from square particle anomalies is almost
impossible to revert.
No living person can touch them unless they have a death
wish.
But if we're lucky, sometimes the squares go away on their
own.
But not before taking away one of my robot's arms or legs or
head.
I cannot stop spinning.
Ah, this is so tedious.
I thought they were shaking hands.
I missed the good old days before our robot repairing robots
broke down.
to be assembled by actual people.
But aren't you a robot?
No?
I mean, do I sound like a robot to you?
Not really.
But your head is a TV.
What does that have to do with anything?
Never mind.
You can't just ask someone if they're a robot, Nico.
Hello?
Oh, shoot.
If I had known you would be here so soon, I would have
turned off the darn lock!
Hello there.
Sorry about the weird security measures.
It's okay.
Adminto helped me solve it.
Yeah, I did.
Actually, I did all of it.
Nico, please give me more credit.
Actually, I did, like, all of it.
Nico.
Did they now?
So, can I help you with anything?
Yeah.
Do you know how I can get a library card?
A library card.
Nico pushed the buttons, though, only because I could not.
You'll have to ask the library for that.
I tried.
I needed to see the head librarian, but I can't get her to
see her without a library card.
But at the same time, she's the only one who gives out
library cards.
Really?
Sounds like George, all right.
She's cute.
She looks like the other, the robot in the, in the Baron.
Sorry you caught her on a bad day.
Aw, wait, I know.
I could just give you my library card.
Won't be hard for me to get another one.
Wow, thanks.
There, you're all set, I think.
Wait, shoot.
I forgot the front desk library bots have facial
recognition.
Oh, and my photo on the card won't match you.
Unless I tape a photo of my face to your face.
Um, that was a joke.
Maybe you'll get lucky and the robot will take it anyway.
Worst comes the worst, you can always find somewhere to take
a photo.
What's this?
Something is poking out from the shelf.
It's a tube of glitter glue.
You can have that if you want.
Never know when you need to glitter things up, right?
Are you sure?
Yeah, I have tons of those.
Thank you.
Glitter.
Oh.
So, you've been walking all over the world, huh?
Mm-hmm.
Jeez, I can't imagine.
Get your photo printed?
Bogo is binted?
Where do you get your photos printed?
Do you get really tired sometimes?
Kinda.
But I don't mind.
It's actually really pretty.
But that's it.
Yes, that's exactly what I saw!
I'm glad you think so.
Even with the sun gone, the world is still a beautiful
place.
What did the world look like with the sun?
Oh.
You know, it's kind of embarrassing to admit how little of
it I have actually seen.
Oh?
Ironic, isn't it?
I'm sending you into orbit.
Why?
Even though I'm the world's leading researcher.
All I can do here...
Wait, this is Kibb.
That's what her thing said, right?
All I can do here is stay here and build robots.
You'll find out.
What did I do?
You're the ones exploring the world.
I just write down the data.
Crunch numbers.
Generate graphs.
Look at this graph.
I've been seeing robots everywhere.
I just thought it was because the world was too dangerous
for most people to explore.
That's not far from the truth, actually.
I know someone who still does his research firsthand.
The author.
Even after segments of land started collapsing and access to
the more remote areas became difficult.
I mean, he outright built a machine that could fly.
Something we all thought was not physically possible.
Oh, that's...
I asked him about working with us, so he provides us with
all sorts of insights.
from time to time.
For some reason, he really didn't want to build robots.
Do you have her necklace?
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking, because it's Kip.
We're more specifically coding them.
How come?
It's me.
I mean, he's happy to work with robots.
In fact, he even...
It's been a while since we last talked.
He must be busy with his books now, yeah?
That's...
How did you get this?
This robot lady in the barren...
gave it to me.
She looked kind of like you.
I see.
He didn't want to spread his code.
Spread my code.
Sad music.
It was supposed to be such a breakthrough, you know?
I even based her on myself, so I'll know it works.
Breakthrough?
We're breaking free!
We wanted to build a robot that acts like Like a person.
Thinks like a person.
A robot that isn't bound by its own code.
Oh!
But turns out you can't really build something like that.
Too many contradictions in their code.
Made her unstable.
I was the only time I've ever seen a robot go rogue.
Scariest day of my life, tell you what?
Rogue.
You know, Nico kind of talks like Snake.
Where are they repeat the same thing?
As the person that said it?
We spreading code in here again?
Oh, yeah.
But she seemed so nice when we talked.
Even if she talked a little weird.
She's been repaired for some time now.
It is an effective conversational technique.
Repeating what they say?
Mm-hmm.
My friend was able to stabilize her volatile state through
his own means.
A real miracle worker thought.
After he was through, she ended up turning out just like how
I wanted.
But the damage was already done.
I gave up on her back then.
Oh, we all did.
I'm sure she realized that.
Now she won't ever come back.
She won't even answer my letters.
Sorry.
Sorry for rambling.
You should hold on to that, Amber, okay?
I will!
What about the strange journal?
I wonder if she knows this.
Don't overwork yourself, okay?
Your journey is just as important as your end goal.
Clich, but true.
She did not know.
Let's just ignore that guy.
So sorry, so sorry for your troubles.
No, that is not Nico one-shot.
Where did I come from?
Here.
We did not go this way, I think.
Oh, wait.
No, we did not.
This area is huge.
It's like blinking a little.
Pretty music.
Remember the water.
I have not forgotten.
Don't you fret.
This little ear is wiggling.
Looks like I can unlock this door.
Oh, is it a shortcut now?
Ha, dag!
Let's go.
I just need to find the elevator.
I don't know where you're gonna...
Is it this?
No, this is the alleyway.
Oh, here it is.
I forgot that we can also fast travel.
Holy cow.
I feel like I've explored most everything, so...
I don't know if I would have been able to fast travel here,
though.
It's fine.
We can check once we're up here.
Yeah, I've been exploring.
I've been going around.
Yeah.
Checking out everything, all the things.
Call me Magellan.
Mint Jellin.
Medicated water.
Good thinking, Admin.
This water should really help the seed grow.
It sprouted a tiny leaf.
Good luck, little plant.
I have the sudden impression that I completely forgot
fast-traveling.
Oh my gosh, we really can!
Wait.
No.
Uh, no, you cannot.
Only, okay, so...
It's only upstairs and downstairs.
I got a...
I have a confession.
I got a friend into Uma Musume.
How should I repent?
Earth-bound ghost.
Oh, earth-bound ghost.
Why would you need to repent?
Spread Uma!
Spread my Uma!
Across the globe!
Alright, now...
We have a library card, so let's travel to the library.
What do you mean?
I know why... Okay.
Do I show it here?
Oh no, the facial recognition!
What a match failed.
It seems you do not resemble the owner of the card.
Bummer.
Okay, oh, we gotta find a place to take our photo.
Um...
Who's your favorite Uma?
Mejiro McQueen!
I love Mejiro McQueen.
Hi Minto!
Hi Ray Ban!
Thank you for six months!
Thank you!
The lens puzzle.
Oh!
Um...
That's right.
I can only do it outside.
I should really get back into the room.
to Uma, but I'm so bad about playing more than one gotcha
game at a time.
It was in Vendor Street, alright?
Yes.
This feels like, uh...
This feels like...
Zoombinis.
Don't ask me why.
There's like that one puzzle.
Is there a hint for this one or...
If you do try out Agnes Digital, you'll love her career.
Oh yeah, I've heard a lot of people saying that.
Ask the guy outside.
Oh, thank you.
Are you here for your photos?
Actually, yeah.
I need to take a picture for reasons.
I don't sound suspicious at all, you guys.
I don't sound suspicious at all.
I've got good news and bad news.
The good news is that the photo center is right behind me.
The bad news is that it doesn't work, right?
You're catching on quick.
After operations ended in the barons, this place got shut
down.
All the engineers lost their jobs and became street vendors.
Maybe Adminto and I can figure it out from them.
That's good.
It would certainly help out people with expired IDs.
Like me.
He used to be one of the camera engineers, right?
Oh, we immediately run up to somebody.
A camera?
Oh, joyous memories.
together.
And by that, I mean the concave lens did.
Can you tell me how to fix the camera?
It's been a while.
Pretty sure that bulgy lens goes on one of the ends, but I
forgot which.
The bulgy lens?
The thick one?
This one?
Thick lens?
Or do they mean...
The... Not the con... Not the concave one?
Or the con...
Bulgy equals convex.
Is there anything you remember about how to work the camera?
When arranging the lenses, make sure that the thin one is
positioned between the two curved ones.
I don't get the camera working.
The thick lens should be positioned to the left of both...
Ah!
Okay.
Alright.
I think we got it then.
I think we got it.
So the thin one is in between.
Okay.
And then the thick one is to the left.
First try.
Easy.
Representing for Simboli Rudolph.
She amazing puns.
Tease.
Out.
My eyes.
Yay!
It's a photo of me and my...
Are my eyes always this big?
see it back of the photo is covered in glue and glitter
photo of nico sticky the card is my face on it now yippee
travel to the library quit staring at me with those big old
eyes are my eyes big my
eyes big if I open my eyes too much they dry.
Blink,
blink, blink, blink, blink, blink, blink, blink, blink,
blink, blink, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip, blip,
blip, wait, I'm not even blinking anymore.
I'm just making the noise.
Oh, wait, the big eyes you have.
Big eyes, poop.
Not big enough, please enhance.
Don't steal a kid!
Come on, I'm the prize.
I'm the prize.
Yeah, I'm the
Barcode, facial recognition.
Photo match successful.
You're good to go.
Have a nice day, Miss Kip.
Time to wipe the kiss marks off my monitor.
Stop it.
Maybe I should have changed the name.
I think she's in there.
It's full.
Looks like an old phone.
Wait, this is the phone we've been calling her on.
Small tree.
Another small tree.
Excuse me.
Hey!
Who the heck do you think you are barging in here like that?
I don't care if you're the Messiah.
Manners are still a thing!
I'm sorry.
Well, are you just here to apologize?
Yes!
No!
I mean, no!
I mean, I need your help.
I'm not sure what I need to do next.
I think I need to go into the tower?
Seriously?
You haven't figured that one out yet?
I think George kind of sucks.
I've met George for two seconds and I'm already...
George's personality is randomly chosen out of the six sides
every time you play the game.
No stinking way.
We got the bad orangey!
I don't know how to get in!
Well, I don't know either.
All I know is that nobody from this world can get in there.
Not beyond that tiny entrance room anyway.
If anything, there might be a book on how the Messiah of all
people can get in.
But I don't think... I don't got anything like that in my
collection.
We got the bad George.
We got the bitchy George.
Who the hell is George?
This dice, this dice right here.
Would like to though.
I see.
I feel like George is a pretty cute name for a girl.
Now I think about it.
I think that's a cute name for a girl.
George.
I feel like it's kind of like a George.
Georgia.
Georgina.
It's cute.
George.
I think it's cute.
The fridge is full of bottled water and takeout boxes.
Well, since you're already here, it'd be rude for me to tell
you to leave.
So you got any questions about books?
Or you can read something here, I don't care.
Just don't make a mess.
Printer.
Metal.
Oh, we got a lot of books here, okay.
Black Clover symbol.
And this other book has a black clover on its spine.
And the rest of these books too.
Oh, they're all about clovers?
George Phantom.
I've met a Georgie before.
Oh, that's cute.
What?
Of course not.
That's just how the author marks his work.
Oh.
Because he has to keep up with his mysterious persona, I
guess.
He's never even told me his name.
Wait, so if he wrote all of these books...
Yes, he did.
Why does she hate me, you guys?
Whoa!
This is about a profit bot.
Oh my god, he has like a little like a little robe and
stuff.
Dr. Silverpoint's team was able to replicate our prototype.
Oh, cute!
What about this one?
Hey, I think this book is actually about clovers.
Oh, the black clover although its pigmentation is primarily
black the leaves display incredible iridescence when exposed
to sunlight whoa these curious plants are most resilient can
even thrive in the metallic sand and harsh climate of the
barons oh my gosh matara con of plants it's a stinking
cockroach and the glen it can also grow directly on top of
the moss layer without competing with the moss for
resources.
Radiocarbon dating of fossils suggests that these plants may
be the first lifeforms to colonize our world.
Sketchbook.
Wednesday.
Another...
Stiff?
Stiff life of some objects on my desk.
Stiff...
What?
Stiff not...
Stiff not very Very good, but silver can recognize the
objects at least.
Thursday, various sketches practice.
Oh, still.
Another still light.
Oh.
I thought it was stiff because they weren't moving.
George one is kind of the opposite of George six.
Same with two and five, three and four.
the opposites also opposites on a six-sided dice cute the
stiff life it's a stiff life for me you gotta get your blood
pumping you gotta stand up get your you gotta move your
bones another fruitful visit to the great prophet today she
seemed a high in spirits she told me that she saw another
glimpse of the messiah's arrival more vivid than ever before
the messiah will in a dark house.
Oh, sorry.
A book on the ground.
She deeply believed in the multiverse theory.
Regarding alternate versions, she likened the probability to
rolling of dice.
Recently, I found the theory easier and easier to believe,
but I could not describe it very well back then.
Nevertheless, I still wrote it to the best of my abilities.
After all, it felt only right to honor her this way.
There are six which one did you encounter read the books in
the library i don't think this is a good time for a nap okay
i'm still confused though we meant two oh sorry i don't mean
to keep clicking what's this picture here i can't see it
never mind what about this one even the painting is books
books.
Wait, so I have to...
Wait, let me show the journal to her.
She probably...
This is what I wanted to do before.
I have this book.
I think it's written in some sort of words I don't
recognize.
Let me see.
Of course.
Of course!
More work for George.
Fine.
Hey, uh, kid?
Nico!
Looks like I'm gonna have to translate this for you Might
take a while.
Oh no.
Nico, don't you know not to say you aren't to me?
Excuse me.
I know that feel, kid.
I'm at a good night's sleeping weeks.
Wasn't sleepy two minutes ago.
But now.
That's not good.
You know what?
I have a guest room.
Okay, go take a nap.
Okay, don't say yours, please.
I should ban it for my... for my...
I'm a little tired from walking.
It's all right if I take a nap.
Yes.
Close the game.
Alright, alright.
Play!
Oh my gosh, Nico.
I ate all the pancakes.
What is that?
Uh-huh.
Broken light bulb.
What's that mean?
Hey, Adminto, I guess you saw my dream?
Yes.
It was...
Scary?
Are you okay?
Come on, let's go.
Spooky, scary dream.
Nightmare.
finally the translation is done oh that was faster than I
thought well yeah you've been asleep for hours oh anyway
looks like this journal was meant for Admin to me read it
yourself greetings Admin to this book was meant for Admin to
how could you tell if you can finally read this that means
you are near the tower The tower is the domain of the
elusive entity.
That's me?
I'm an entity!
This being is connected to the world.
For now, you can think of it as the spirit of the world.
It has no physical form, but it can communicate through
computers and other machinery.
You know who I am talking about, of course.
When you first arrived here with our Savior, it is no
doubt...
It no doubt contacted you right away.
Steam?
Gabe's team?
Though its own means, the entity will guide the both of you
to the tower.
The entry room is at the tower's base.
Not only do you need the sun there, but also three pieces of
the previous sun.
The savior will not be able to do anything there.
You, Adminto, on the other hand.
Look at the pattern on the floor.
Do as it says.
The window will be gone, so you need to bring it back.
That's all there is.
Someone tore out the other pages.
Did you do this?
No.
And you're on your own, kid.
I'm not sure what window...
Window means here.
Probably like the window...
Like...
This...
This window.
But...
Maybe Anminto will have to figure that out.
That one.
Ray.
By the way, what does it mean by three pieces of the
pre-pages?
previous sun.
The winto?
Winto?
WW, flip it around.
Minto?
I only have this sun.
Do I have to explain everything?
It's just a fancy word for objects containing yellow
phosphor.
You know, stuff that glows yellow.
Oh.
I do have a piece of amber and a feather.
They fit the description, right?
Yeah, but you only have two of them, and they're super rare,
so it's not like you're gonna find something like that on
the ground.
Right.
Okay.
Here, you can have this.
No!
Nico, the character was actually created on December 28th.
It's their birthday.
What?
Wait.
Actually?
No way!
Happy birthday, Nico!
Happy birthday!
Oh, it looks kind of like you.
What?
I've never seen dice before?
No?
I mean, yes?
I mean, it's just... never mind.
So, yeah.
Need anything else?
I'm good, thank you.
Off you go, then.
Don't screw this up, okay?
Nico is 12 years old in real life.
Happy birthday, Nico.
Wait, it's the pancakes?
Is that what?
We get the pancakes?
To Nico.
Oh.
Oh my god, I thought that was me.
Hey, Admin, do you remember where the cafe is?
Yes.
Oh, good.
I'm asking because, well...
Oh, hungry.
Actually, I'm really hungry.
I haven't eaten anything since I got here.
Let's go get some food before we enter the tower.
I hope they have pancakes.
Alright.
That was so well timed.
Oh my gosh.
I'm also hungry though.
I do have some food I can eat.
But I was gonna wait until after stream.
But I think I have still quite a bit to go, no?
Mm-hmm.
Take a break, it's okay.
Oh, hey, you're back.
You're close to the end of the first part.
Wait, first part.
Did you manage to fix the elevator?
Mm-hmm.
And Minto and I went to the surface already.
And...
Well, I remembered there being a cafe here.
Do you have pancakes?
We sure do.
Wait, I don't have any money.
Maybe I can help you wash dishes or something.
It's on the house.
At least I can do for the Savior, right?
Here, why don't you take a seat?
I'll go fry some up for you.
Pancakes.
These eyes are so cute.
These pancakes are so good.
Thank you so much.
No problem.
You looked really hungry.
Yeah, I thought this would be my last chance to eat
something before I go in the tower.
Gotcha.
So I guess pancakes are your favorite food?
Mm-hmm.
Well, almost.
The stomach growls are too realistic.
I know!
You guys, I'm gonna go grab my food.
I'll be right back.
Thank you for all the super times!
Yummy.
Okay.
Sandwich time.
Um...
I forgot a napkin.
Mmm, I like the music.
Mungo mungo mungo suge!
Oishi!
YouTube censors hot mom.
So I've come here to finally say all these pancakes are
missing.
Are Nico's hot mom.
So you want Nico's mom.
Nico's mom is got it going on.
Okay, okay.
Wait, continue.
My favorite food in the world are the special pancakes that
my mama makes.
She likes to pick hazelnuts and grind them up in the batter?
Wait, that sounds amazing.
Yeah, that's what I just said.
Mugugug.
They taste amazing.
She always made them when I was feeling sad.
We're lonely.
Or...
Oh, cry.
I also miss Ayami, mama.
Oh, it came through.
Thank you for the dodo.
There's an anniversary game that shows the recipe for his
mom's pancakes.
I want to try it.
Maybe we could do that on stream.
Or I make the pancakes.
But right now, my setup...
My current maid cafe is not very good for, like, home
cooking streams or...
anything like that so maybe in the future whenever I move we
could do it afterwards
I just I just have a bad feeling all of a sudden am I even
here to save the world people have been saying how the sun
won't fix anything I don't even know why I'm here
I just want to see my mama again
They're there!
It's gonna be okay!
And I'm sure you'll be able to save the world.
You're a tough kid.
You managed to get this far already, right?
Yeah, but...
And they'll get to go home afterwards, right?
Right!
Yeah, Nico.
This is a Denny's.
Poor guy.
Hey, I want some more pancakes.
It's okay.
You are suck.
No, I'm just kidding.
be fun yeah poor little guy so stressed out he's actually so
strong because it's like nico has been all over the place
transported isekai to a different world and told that they
are the savior of the world and has not complained about it
even once it's just been like okay yeah i'll do the thing
you know poor guy
uh thanks for coming by Thanks for listening M for the
pancakes No problem Good luck Pancakes favorite food I don't
know where I need to go though That's my issue
Poor little guy
I don't think I saw the Entrance of the tower did I?
That's why I meant I don't know where to go.
I don't know if I ever ran into it.
Thanks!
Oh, where was that?
It was
like...
Was it a near?
No.
But we like went somewhere.
This area confuses me.
Looks very similar, everything.
The shortcut.
Ah!
Was it?
It was in the shortcut, was it?
Right here.
This is the shortcut.
Yes!
Thank you guys.
Yes.
So what did I need to do with the window?
I might
have made a mistake there, but
It's scary to do it, though
Is this the inside of the tower?
It's a lot darker than I thought Wait Where's the sun?
Adminto, do you know what happened to the sun?
Adminto?
Wait, Nico, can't hear me?
Admital!
Niko!
Say something!
Oh, we could still control him though.
We had no items.
Don't tell her what pressing the X did in the original
version of the game.
Oh gosh.
I want to know after I complete everything.
Am I going the wrong way?
Left or right?
Yeah, let's try a different...
Something?
Someone?
Somewhere?
Oh,
okay.
He said he's afraid of the dark.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Hello, Nico.
Hello.
Congratulations.
You are now inside the tower.
Are you talking to me now?
Correct.
You were always talking to Adminto before.
Where's...
Adminto has already left...
No!
I'm right here!
I had to resort to contacting you directly.
Adminto is gone just like that?
Correct.
Adminto has already finished their mission.
And so have you, Nico.
Here, you can rest now.
Everything that's happened here is like a bad trip.
When you wake up, you will be home.
But...
What's wrong?
I thought there'd be more to it, you know.
I thought we were supposed to go to the top of the tower.
I thought there was supposed to be somewhere we needed to
put the sun in.
Now I don't even have the sun anymore.
And Minto is just gone.
This feels wrong.
But you did good.
You saved the world, Nico.
Are you not happy?
I guess I am.
But it's just...
Did they just turn off the computer?
Oh, so rude.
I never even got to say goodbye to En...
I'm right here, Nico!
Eyes wide open.
And as for you, Anminto, we're done here.
Please don't return to this world anymore.
Is that the first ending, I suppose?
What?
Don't listen, you're right.
this is not over regardless of what the entity told you
there's more to the story documents my game's one shot look
for this symbol once it is active please relaunch the game
see you soon oh
uh wait I just activated the game again okay oh oh okay uh
what was it?
Documents uh wait hold on the
Documents?
My games.
Oh, here we go.
Here, I'll show you guys this one at least.
One shot.
Oh!
Wait, it's a whole...
Read me.
Oh, that's kind of fun.
I didn't even notice this.
It's a whole EXE file.
Now I open the game?
I'm scared.
Nico!
Hello?
Admito!
Was that you just now?
I thought I heard your voice.
In my dream!
I guess you're still not here.
Wait, there's something in my pocket.
I don't remember putting it there.
Readme.txt is my favorite computer file!
Whoa, it's like...
glowing you're still here nico why are you still here ew
it's angry at me why did you come back edminto i told you to
stay away you knew i tried to cut the story short is that it
you want more out of me is that it fine if you don't want to
leave i'll make sure you never do
Hold on, let me, like, close this.
But then I told you about the entity as little as possible.
What is this?
Wait, what is this?
Is it telling us where to go?
No, stinking way.
Wait, is it really?
Oh, but it's like...
Oh my god.
Apologies for that.
I did not want to put the librarian in danger.
Wait.
Do I just go up?
So up this time.
Oh my god.
This has been a habit of silencing the people who learned of
its true nature.
Sorry that I have to keep clicking in and out of the
different windows.
Oh, I lined it up with this.
I see.
Oh, cool.
You can keep the note.
But I can't move if I do that.
That's the thing.
Like, I can't move my...
I can't move the character.
So I have to.
Incredibly, I have seen it happen to dear friends.
You were supposed to be clicking in and out.
Okay, okay.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Who cares?
It's fine.
We're doing it.
Ah, but not to worry.
The entity But he cannot touch you.
Which way am I supposed to go here?
Wait, huh?
Do I go back left?
Again?
Maybe?
Nor can it do anything to me.
Look it down.
This is crazy.
I'm glad I did a desktop share for this.
I have already left the world on my own terms.
This is so cool!
I never meant for the entity to exist.
Oh.
But now that it's fully sentient, one thing became clear.
I can't find the glow worm.
Is this it?
There it is, yeah.
This last door?
The entity seeks death.
The left door.
I hope that was the right one.
Death to itself, death to the world.
A relentless desire that manifested physically.
Wait, these sound effects sound like, what's it called?
Mortis.
Faith.
They sound like faith sound effects.
Do you hear it?
They're pretty quiet though.
You have already seen the scars.
Listen, listen, listen.
It'll turn it up even.
This it is!
I don't like it.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Right now, the entity is doing everything it can to impede
your progress, stalling for even a few minutes.
Wait, it's...
That door to the right.
Okay.
No!
My controller!
It just sent me back a little bit.
That's okay.
sorry so sorry desire to death yeah I've already seen the
scars
it's the same one right yes okay oh my gosh there we go okay
before you inevitably bring the sun to the tower's summit.
Oh, there's only other one at the door.
This, that's, that is where you, God, will make the final
judgment for the world.
Where's, uh, where's
our...
This is so interesting.
Of course the entity will contact you again there.
The middle.
Oh gosh, okay, I'm gonna do my best.
Huh, huh, huh.
Ugh, there we go.
And when it does, it will trick you into shattering the sun.
This one right here.
This will end the world instantly!
This one here.
This is craziness.
Why just dot, dot, dot, dot?
Why?
No.
It is not that simple.
I'm sorry, I do not know what to do in a situation like
this.
The middle one?
Middle.
That is very fitting that you're playing this game after
getting us pregnant on Christmas because Nico is my precious
sword!
But I think I have to tell you the truth.
The sun is the Messiah's tie to the world.
Wait, is the middle one right there?
I think I see it, yeah.
This one?
Oh my gosh, okay.
As long as the sun is intact, the Messiah remains trapped
here.
This is tricky!
Without...
I can't walk!
See?
Oh, this is tricky!
It's like this.
I might have made a mistake but that's fine.
Oh wait.
Oh okay.
That's fine.
We'll just continue.
And then we'll do this.
I don't know how far over it is.
Okay, two more.
This is tedious.
Bit of an oopsie?
Okay!
Chattering the sun may terminate this world, but...
Oh!
Try using the arrow keys.
Uh...
Wait, um...
I don't have a keyboard.
I just...
I don't have a proper keyboard, sorry.
Uh, yeah, I don't have a proper keyboard.
Okay, hold on.
It's not so bad.
It's fine.
It's a game.
Oh, geez.
It is also the only way for the Messiah to return home.
Okay, this one's actually tough.
Wait, this one's really hard!
Start here?
Yeah.
Wait, I think I messed that up.
Yes, I did.
Okay, wait.
Oh, I messed it up!
Oh no!
But I have to get inside there anyway, so let's just get in.
We're going in.
The corners touch.
Oh my gosh.
This part's too tedious.
Game, this part's too tedious.
I'll redo it.
I don't want to do it anymore.
Game!
This part's too tedious.
Please delete it from your...
Delete it.
I don't want to do it anymore.
Developer, make the game easier.
Game?
I'm tired.
Devs redo the game right now in real time.
Is it symmetrical?
Please say yes.
Yes.
Okay, let's go get rid of that one part.
Yeah, please patch this part of the game.
For dummies like me.
For lazy people like me.
Oh, we got it!
Oh my gosh, whoa!
It was like creating the portal entrance.
Oh, why did I go all the way around?
I'm making it more difficult for me.
It's the light bulb!
Thank goodness it's safe.
Oh, the message.
I did not realize things could end up like this.
Please forgive me.
We'll put that over there so that we can see if it changes
again.
coming back.
Dad, when to go get milk?
Nico, I'm here.
Amito playing one-shot is like a birthday present.
Jake, is it your birthday?
Is it your birthday?
I'm a hag now.
Happy birthday!
We'll save this world and Nico for you.
Nico, I'm here.
Admin, go.
Is that really you?
I thought you were gone.
I never left you.
I was feeling a bit scared back there.
I thought I was completely alone.
That was silly of me to assume, wasn't it?
I guess we need to figure out where to go now and...
The sun...
It lit up on its own!
Pick it up.
All right, right?
I mean, too.
Yes.
Here comes the sun.
And I say...
Nico's alright.
It's the house, but...
Wait, is this his house?
It's normal now.
The wood is neatly stacked in the fireplace.
bed the plant is alive it's a little tree despite everything
it's still you is there only alcohol there's nothing in the
fridge oh
so you actually made it here I guess you win Adminto I'll
tell you how to save the world then when you reach the sun
Damn it, shatter the light bulb.
What?
Can you guys hear like the brum?
Brum.
Can you guys hear that?
Okay.
Also, the note disappeared.
It's kind of funny, right?
It really puts you like in the mood of like them taking over
your computer.
I'm just humoring you.
I know you've been getting help from a certain someone.
He already told you about the choice.
didn't he are you still planning to save the world Edminto
why are you trying so hard for this how much you figured out
what this world is certain someone yeah my chat I told you
at the beginning your mission is to help Nico leave because
Nico isn't part of this world Nico is the only thing worth
saving here what the final choice is up to you.
I can't go against my programming.
You have only one...
You only have one shot, Admin, though!
If you choose to smash the light bulb, then Nico wakes up
back home like it was all a dream.
But if you let Nico return the sun, the child will have to
bear the weight of his sacrifice.
Wait.
I can't... I can't tell...
Actually, at least tell Nico the truth!
You do care about Nico, don't you?
I feel like I'm getting manipulated, hardcore.
Sure it's taking a while.
I guess this elevator leads to the top of the tower, Admin,
though.
Are you excited, Admin, though?
We're finally gonna save the world.
And I know it's for real this time because you're here!
I'll get to go home for real this time too!
I can't wait to see everyone again.
Are you okay, Admin?
You seem a little quiet.
Nico!
Yeah?
I need to tell you something.
I'm listening.
We can't save both.
Wait!
The world and...
What's that supposed to mean?
To send you home.
We must break the light bulb.
But what?
Yeah.
I don't want that to happen.
So what happens when we save the world?
What happens to me?
The music is like, oh...
Wait, do we know if that actually will...
That's what I'm saying, is we're just trusting these guys.
But have they ever done this before?
How do they know?
Unless it was the prophecy.
But still...
I don't know.
You don't?
I'm being honest with them, just like I was about pancakes.
I feel like the entity is steering us off track.
right but the note wasn't trying to trick us it was helping
us and it told us the same thing but what if the note is in
cahoots with the what what if the note is in cahoots why
am I the trolley problem but also everyone in this world
says that the world is is done for do we save or do we
re-sacrifice Nico to save a dying world.
But also...
But also, the everybody that lived here, so many people.
You only have one shot.
I know!
So this is where the sun belongs.
If I put the sun in here, we'll be able to save the world,
right?
But if I want to go home, I'll have to break it.
Oh.
Edmito!
What should I do?
What's the right thing to do?
I think we need to return the sun!
You're right.
You can't just leave everyone here to die.
Thank you for your help, Edmito!
I promise I'll be okay!
Wait, that's a credits?
Oh no, they're all gonna see the sun!
No, they're all gonna know, they're all gonna see that it
was saved!
Oh!
The siblings!
Was that silver?
I
don't remember that fox though.
That fox had to come back.
I think there's something else we can do.
Wait, do I have to play the whole game all the way through?
To do it again?
Wait, is it now with the sun?
Oh.
Check the documents?
One second.
Oh, wait.
Is it this?
Save progress.
Do I have to delete this?
And the original freeware game, clicking the X anywhere in
the tower makes Nico die, locking the title screen, and
forcing re-install the game.
What?
Do they read me?
I already did it before.
Did it change?
Wait a second.
Oh, sorry.
I keep having to switch my mice.
I'm doing them.
I'm like...
I'm all over the place.
Okay, here we go.
uh permanent consequences um
this is all the same thing i think right there should be a
note maybe i need to refresh no check the clover
oh looks like you completed your mission in the world and i
understand i know you wish to return but the entity called
itself one shot for a reason that restriction was
implemented a long time ago removing it is impossible now at
least for me i do not know the full extent of your power so
pardon me if this sounds foolish but if you would be so kind
to test something out for me the log of your saved progress
may exist somewhere on your machine yeah we have that right
here maybe even in the same location as this journal you are
reading now if this if this saved progress log takes the
form of a file perhaps you can manipulate it try removing it
from its current location A simple deletion will do.
Again, I apologize for not knowing the extent of your
powers.
If what I described confuses you, I am sorry.
Wait, close.
Delete.
Oh, sorry.
I'm pressing my actual computer.
I'm pressing my actual PC.
Oh, wait.
Delete.
There we go.
Play.
It
closed out- oh?
It closed out even faster than before.
Um, excuse me!
Delete.
Return.
Hello?
Admito?
Wait, why did I say that word?
Admito!
Why does that sound so familiar?
The door is locked.
Hint documents.
What do you mean hint documents?
Eh?
Oh, main documents folder.
Oh, hold on.
There's nothing in here, I think, but just in case.
I'm being a little paranoid, but you know.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, one second, one second, one second.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, here.
Whoops.
It looks like you were able to remove the restriction.
In that case, you are ready to continue the necessary
preparations in place.
This session might run a very different course depending on
your actions.
If you can recognize my symbol, you will know what you
should do.
I confess, it will be risky.
Where are the Dogens?
Definitely not on this computer!
The probability that the entity's condition will worsen is
quite high, and if that happens, then...
Haha, look at me.
Asking you for favors.
Only to become so apprehensive once you agree.
Soul?
Soul-sy.
I understand if you wish to leave some questions unanswered.
you understand if you do not believe in a happy resolution
understand if you are simply afraid of what might happen
because I'm afraid too if you enjoy the world as is if you
are satisfied with the story as is if you really do not want
so solstice big ham welcome back thank you
solstice if you do not want to see anything change for the
better or for the worst then pretend you never saw this
carry the sessions as you normally would do not use my
journal for anything other than what you would you were
already familiar with this option will always remain for you
though solstice that's why i implore you to consider the
messiah the world my children they all deserve their good
ending thank you for listening goodbye is that the password
wait how do you spell it
solstice access granted
You found me.
Why?
Oh, this is all from the beginning of the first time.
More importantly.
This does not...
No, this does not feel right at all.
Have we already been through this?
Admin-to.
But that should be impossible.
You only had one shy.
It wasn't supposed to exist after that.
Nico hears the sound of a door.
unlock.
Ad minto.
That sounds so familiar.
Okay, be honest with me now, everybody.
Be honest with me.
Two shots.
I've got two shots.
How long does this part of the game take?
Two to four hours.
Six hours.
No, six hours so far.
Holy cow.
Three to four hours more.
Two thirds of the way game.
Why did the internet lied to me?
It took like a six to seven hour game.
Shorter than the first but still long.
If, okay.
I'm gonna ask you guys something.
Because we completed the first ending.
Is it okay?
If we say that I beat the game for my sake of beating 50
games.
And then after...
Then after...
Like, I could stop the stream here and then later this week
we'd finish it.
If we did get a real ending...
That's literally the original ending.
Oh yeah!
I think this is new game plus so it's fine.
Okay, okay.
How many games ago?
I finished it on New Year's Eve, so...
We did see credits.
You're so right.
We saw credits, everybody.
We saw credits.
I say it's okay, you got the credits, so finish the game.
Yeah, I think so.
Promise you'll come back, though.
We will, we will.
I'll do it this week, even.
I'll put it on my schedule.
Okay.
Okay!
If you considered that you finished Silent Hill F without
all the endings, I don't see why you shouldn't, this
shouldn't be the same.
You know what, that's true.
I'm drunk and I have no idea what's going on.
There's Carl.
It's worth it to do the run, it's super different.
Well, I'll still do it, don't get me wrong.
But if we're okay with this counting towards a...
Otherwise, yeah.
If we're okay with this counting towards...
My 50 games.
Which everyone seems to be.
seems okay with.
Then we will.
We will do that.
Yay!
It feels a little awkward to say that we beat it, but but
we'll count it for the sake of my sanity.
Tomorrow I'm going to be doing Crow Country So another
longer stream.
And then Tuesday, I will be finishing Battle Block with
Berrybug.
And Friday.
I'm sorry, Friday.
Sorry.
New Year's Eve.
I will be beating a game that I actually have not done on
stream.
And I actually have not beat myself, which is so funny.
But my own very game, Freak Retreat, we will finish the year
with Freak Retreat for New Year's.
And that will be my 50th game!
So, yeah!
I'm playing Crow Country right now.
Yeah, I've kind of put it off for a while.
Because I don't think it's a...
I'm not quite sure if it's a type of game that I'll like.
So I've been putting it off and putting it off.
But so many people have told me that.
That I should play it.
So I said I would.
Yeah, so then we'll have...
We'll have, uh, 50 games this year.
Don't feel awkward.
This part of the game, the Solstice Upstate, didn't exist in
the first months of the game's release, so you literally
beat it.
Oh, okay, cool.
But it still feels like a strange ending, though, no?
No!
It's like PS1 Resident Evil.
I know.
And that's why I'm not sure if I'll like it.
That's why I'm not sure.
If I will like it.
But I am willing to give it a chance.
I'm willing to give it a chance.
So, you know, whatever.
I don't want to just put it off.
Just because it's similar to another game.
It's not punishing.
Okay, good.
The camera angles aren't as bad.
Hmm.
But yeah, we'll do that.
You played Signalist, didn't you?
I did.
Is it similar?
The original game was...
Made very quickly.
Quickly, this is a quick game for a contest.
This is the true and complete version.
Maybe you'll be eating crow.
Dispatch is pretty fun.
Any interest in playing that?
Well, since I, towards the end of the year, I've been
focusing on just, you know, obviously I wanted to do things
that I wanted to play, but also I had to focus on games that
I could beat easily.
Now I can get back to longer games, so...
Dispatch seems interesting, especially because I learned one
of the characters is voiced by Jesse's actor from Breaking
Bad.
So, I kind of want to...
I want to play it.
Yeah!
Aaron Paul, yeah, yeah, yeah, the main character.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, I learned that literally yesterday, and I was like, oh,
I know Dispatch is kind of popular.
Maybe I'll, or like, it was, it was, it was all around.
he sounds so different in Dispatch.
He's a great actor.
Oh,
I will, I will probably put it on my list of things.
I'm looking at my list of games that I want to do at the
moment.
Don't let chat backseat too hard on this badge.
I won't.
This game got the tears running again, even though I played
it many years ago.
Now I'm excited to get the true ending.
Actually, let me put it in my calendar too, so that I
don't...
Sorry for no schedule this past week, but of course there
will be one this week, so...
Let me do...
One shot.
In fact, I can do that at New Year's.
We could do it New Year's Day.
I wasn't going to stream because I'll be up at like 3 in the
morning with Doki.
So I was going to take New Year's off, actually.
Markiplier left Nico in the tower.
Doki, thank you for the gift, Kiwi Lemon Lime.
Welcome back.
Oh my gosh, I love.
I thought your profile picture was like a lemon.
slice at first, but I see what it is now.
I love it.
Let's see.
Maybe I will do one shot day after.
I might be too tired to do it on New Year's.
Can you even close the game right now?
I should be able to, right, everybody?
I should be able to, right?
It'll probably just, like...
It'll probably...
Just, uh...
Have me do this part again, I imagine.
That's okay.
If I have to input solstice again, that's okay.
Finish this dialogue first?
Okay, let's finish the dialogue first.
Hello?
Anyone?
Oh.
Here, I'll even leave the house.
We gotta go get the bulb.
The fastest dialogue in the West.
Here, we'll get the bulb and we'll leave, and then we'll...
Wait.
Oh, do I have to do the... Okay.
Yeah, we have to do all this again.
I think if I were to Wait, what did I do for this?
Oh my gosh, it was so seven hours ago Oh, the twig, that's
right, the twig
Okay There we go Strange journal, wait, what is this?
Cool, we have this right now
Oh wait, how did I light this?
the sparks of the TV.
That's right.
Thank you, guys.
Okay.
Basement key.
What's nice is we can kind of fast track a little bit
through it.
Because we've read all this dialogue.
I've played these games before.
Thanks for the stream.
I've only been here for 30 minutes.
Thanks for sticking around, though.
Thank you.
Light bulb.
I'm just gonna leave the house and then we'll call it there.
And I can get the first episode of Season 3 Breaking Bad in
tonight, I think.
Oh, yeah!
I'm addicted.
Okay.
Once we're out here, all right.
you play one of my favorite indie games?
This has been so cool!
The, I love the notes part, it was so awesome.
Congrats on clearing another gaming key!
So I know I need to confess during the collab yesterday when
you said cheeks were your charm point.
I did, I actually did mean your face cheeks.
You did!
You did, you did!
You like my cheeks?
Oh my gosh, I'm zooming in so much today.
Both of them.
Both of them, huh?
Wow, I can't.
I can't.
You are only...
You are only Aibu.
You are a simple Aibu.
I cannot.
I can't fault you.
Guys, I think Minto is extra cute today.
I'm extra cute because I had lots of fun!
Thank you guys for streaming Thanks for hanging out with me
I will see you when I see you Next Otubito We'll finish one
shot this week I promise I pinky pinky promise Wait, I'll
finish one shot Next year Otubito Otubito Otubito Bye bye Bye-bye